and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists welcome to episode 155
we have a special guest in the studio
with us today we're here with Peter
Rollins Ryan I love you I love you more
today we know I love more than you Peter
Rollins this is a beautiful moment I'm
seeing I feel like I should leave the
room no way did we ask you to be here
with us I'll share this love thank you
we film all of our most intimate moments
yep today we're gonna be talking about
love and we're here with Peter Rollins
Peter you well this is only the second
time we've ever met the first time we
met was about a year ago we did an event
in Los Angeles with our shared friend
Rob Bell yeah and you came out for that
thank you for for showing up and we had
a really great time at that event it was
one of my favorite live podcast that
we've ever done I thought you would have
me on the stage but that's why I was
there and since then you know I've
really enjoyed you've had a few
conversations on Rob Bell's podcast I'm
gonna do our best today to not just
reiterate those conversations but you
had this series of three conversations
last summer and we'll put links to all
three of these in the show notes about
love and man youuuu sort of talked about
well I don't again I don't want to
rehash all of it but there were a few
things that really stood out now Ryan
and I we end every podcast episode with
a phrase the sort of mantra that we've
come up with and it's a repurposing of
several different quotes but it's love
people and use things because the
opposite never works
and I feel like in our society what
we've done now is we have commodified
the people in our lives quite often and
it's become almost a default especially
via the technologies that we use now and
just The Consumerist culture we've come
if I'd the people in our lives and we're
loving the commodities and in our life
and you said a few things during those
those podcast conversations with Rob
Bell that they really stood out to me
one of the quotes that I wrote down here
was he said love is not meaningful love
is what brings meaning into the world
and to me that was that was just it was
it was beautiful because I think quite
often we're looking for what we're
chasing happiness we're chasing pleasure
were chasing ephemerality and I think
that's often the wrong pursuit were
we're really looking for meaning in life
but but and love if we're looking for
meaning in love is what brings that that
meaning into the world maybe you can
expand on on that a little bit yeah
basically and everybody knows as soon as
I said everyone go oh yeah of course
it's that you know when you love
somebody or when you love a cause that
love makes everything reading it really
kind of brings depth and density to your
life it makes walks not just getting
from A to B but they can be like a
communion with nature it makes a meal
not simply giving yourself energy to
survive but it can become a type of you
know communion with another person and
so where and when you lose love often
what happens is everything becomes
meaningless you know you don't just lose
one thing right you don't have a hundred
things in your life that are meaningful
and then oh I've lost one thing that was
meaningful but I still have 99 that are
yes exactly one one's gone but 99 or
impious and sadly when you lose love you
can lose the meaning that you get rid of
everything else suddenly getting out of
bed becomes a chore going to work is not
something that you enjoy if you enjoy
your work everything becomes gray so in
a sense when you love someone or when
you love a cause it it basically Arnim
it's your entire existence and when that
is lost
we are under threat of basically we are
under threat of losing care and concern
for the world yeah I love how that the
concept is love is almost the motivation
or the inspiration instead of us
reacting on the love maybe it's just
focusing on developing the love more I
don't know that makes any sense but I
yeah I love that approach in the other
the other line that really stood out to
me that that I sent over to my wife as
soon as as soon as the the whole I was
realistic to this this series in
preparation for this podcast by the way
we we don't do interviews so I don't
want to turn this into a whole interview
thing what we do is we show up and we
answer questions we have some questions
from audience we'll get to in a second
but there was one of the line that
really stood out to me and I wanted to
bring it to the forefront and I think
it's gonna be applicable for the
questions are gonna be answering today
but when you said love is giving up what
you do not have to someone who does not
want it and I believe it was a quote
from a philosopher and that was so
powerful giving up what you love is
giving up what you do not giving giving
what you do not have to to someone who
does not want it meaning like like the
pain and the suffering like like what
you do not have to someone who's able to
sort of support you and deal with it not
withstanding the pain yeah I mean it's
definitely a difficult quote to unpack
but but if we unpack it if you go onto
tinder or something like that we're
always giving of our excess I'm you know
I'm smart I like this I travel the world
you've got pictures that show you you
know the access of your life you know
you give over this image that that that
you're pretty cool and people want that
you know you want to meet somebody who
is he's got it all together he loves
exciting things he's gonna fulfill your
life in some way make it richer but
we're really treating people as objects
in that way you know we're seeing them
with a certain number of criteria that
they can give us right there's nothing
for me there's nothing overly wrong with
that I mean I want my friends to
selfishly like me but for whatever I
thought I don't think it's love so that
quotes which is a paraphrase of Lacan
you know one way of describing it is you
knew he loves somebody
when you give them what you don't have
and what you don't have is your luck
what you don't have is your pian your
difficulties that the stuff that you
know you know all your excess but your
inadequacy your inadequacies and then
nobody wants that really so when when
you meet somebody who you can share
those inadequacies with and they want
them they can take them all and even
celebrate them and nurture them and and
hold a space for them then you can say
wow that's a miracle
that's love and that's pray it's so rare
to see you know this is so rare for us
to experience I think we want to always
be the best version of ourselves right
and so like I know that with me and with
any of my friends like I do want to be
the best version of myself but sometimes
my expectation even for mice or
especially for myself is is too high and
and we all want to be you know perform
at the level of a superhero but that's
not human yeah and that's not love
that's not connection that is
performance yes we all do it to a
certain extent it's it's kind of like
the selfie phenomenon where you know we
take a selfie where we look hopefully
pretty good and it may be it if we're
into might in the earring or something
like that we'll show a selfie of us up a
mountain or if we like yoga or even a
selfie where we're not even in us but it
kind of we take a picture of a cool car
or some environment that reflects
something of our values and so in a
sense when we do that we're putting out
an idealized version of ourselves and
there's new problems without people
laugh and say selfies are never just
selfies are always for somebody else but
it would be much weirder if you just
took selfies for yourself if you just
took selfies and then put them in an
album and then just looked at them on a
Thursday evening and never shoot them
with that to anybody else you know we
won't see project like these images
however they also hide a lot and they
hide our insecurities and they hide our
lack and whenever you have a loving
relationship that lock is also able to
be seen yeah and being vulnerable with
the other person they appreciate you
because of that because they get to see
that
other side that maybe the the world
doesn't get to see because there's other
side of it too I mean you see this
sometimes online where that there's sort
of this this the the vapid side of the
was me and that's the other side of the
the the selfie whether it's it's photo
based or textual it's it's oh my God my
life is crumbling like constant like
it's the addiction to to the suffering
in a way and sharing the suffering which
is which is the other side of the coin
because it's only when you have an image
of a type of perfection that you think
you would like that you get depressed
because you don't live up to it if you
can have a healthier view that we are
all i mean basically all of us live
between who we are and who we would like
to be and between what we have and what
we would like to have we live in the
space of the in-between and the more we
try to get the thing that we want and be
the person that we want the more
depressed we are if we don't get up or
the more melancholy we are if we do get
it you know this idea that we live
between depression and melancholy
depression is the unhappiness of not
getting what you want and melancholy is
the unhappiness of getting what you want
right um so we're in this interesting
dilemma and the challenge is to break
free of that entire way of thinking and
therefore you get rid of both the excess
of I'm incredible I'm brilliance you
know fiction but also you get rid of
this despair as well which is a
different kind of fiction yeah where
everything is terrible
yeah and there's a show that I've been
watching now called a better call Saul
are you familiar with this Bob Odenkirk
I know the original series of that's
about how much better call so this is
like the really boring version of
Breaking Bad is the way I could describe
it but but there's sort of a lot of
existential angst in the main character
but he's in a way addicted to failure I
mean there's this line toward the end of
the fourth season that just ended and
where the main character is talking to
his significant other and
they're having this argument he goes and
she says something to him that is very
poignant and and but but pretty sharp
and he says oh sure kick me while I'm
down
and she says Jimmy you're always down
yeah and and and it's he's addicted to
that that that despair that being down
all the time this is this is by the way
something we can't you know get deeply
into it but this is ubiquitous this idea
I love with the phrase you used addicted
to what was it addictive should feel
you're being detected to feel there's I
we think there's a common notion that
human beings are you know selfish in the
sense of they want the best for
themselves you want to maximize your
pleasure minimize your p.m. you know
utilitarianism
but in psychoanalysis there is this
insight that actually we're really bad
utilitarians but sometimes we can really
want the worst for ourselves that we
undertake example people think that
gamblers are addicted to winning but to
be honest most gamblers are addicted to
losing and what happens is I don't know
if you ever play poker or anything but
if you lose some hands what happens is
you go on tilts and on tilt means you
start betting more frantically and part
of the psychology of this is when you're
losing it makes the win seem even more
incredible so it's like if a gambler
playing slot machines always won it
would be boring right you might win some
money but it would be ultimately really
boring but the fact that you lose a lot
January it's a foul to say that oh my
goodness if only I could win and all of
my problems would be solved and so we
weirdly get into this thing where we're
addicted to the loss is the loss that
generates the excess of attachment to
some fantasy because it makes the wind
that much better much better whereas an
awesome perspective if you were winning
all the time though all of a sudden
you're going to get bored and more more
and then you're gonna get pissed off at
some point because like you never run
into someone who you really respect and
appreciate where you really look up to
them you say well what are your secret
and they said well I'm just really great
at winning I win all the time I mean you
see crazy people do that when when
Charlie Sheen was having his famous
meltdown like the hashtag
winning like you realize like that's not
winning that is the that is the facade
of winning around a sort of crumbling
interior yeah we live in us in a weird
freedom in which in our society the
losers lose EE but even the winners
loose so I mean T it's funny if you take
an example of a prosperity Church for
example and people sometimes ask why do
people go to prosperity churches like a
Joel Wilson person you follow three it
is he is the one person I follow I find
it fascinating
[Laughter]
Peter why should I follow Joel Osteen on
Twitter but I have too many questions to
ask you so yeah somebody actually
created a jewel Rollins thing Twitter
briefly we're at it mashed together
jewel little stink foots and Kreutz for
me it was very funny was it the weird
thing is like I heard in a most the most
charitable sort of attribution towards
someone like a Joel Osteen and then
we'll get back to the I don't mean to
cut you off here now but the most
charitable saying is that the Joel
Osteen is sort of reap Aron ting some
people who maybe didn't have that sort
of you he didn't have exposure to those
basic aphorisms when they were growing
up and I know I didn't it would but it
was possible for me to you know Ryan and
I grew up in probably nothing is
troubling as the troubles in Northern
Ireland was yes but but we had our own
troubles we grew up in Dayton Ohio it's
the overdose capital of America a lot of
drug and alcohol abuse and in our
childhoods and and I know a lot of that
sort of wisdom would have been helpful
to us at the time and so in a way like
it's almost as if he's like reap Aron
ting and there's a sort of
infantilization that's going on in the
congregation's there but maybe it's
maybe some of those aphorisms are
helpful but but also at the same time I
think that the infantilizing only goes
so far to where it's well you want to
put your head through a wall yeah
yeah and yeah the question is to what
extent does one and I'm talking about
Wilson here but there's one keep people
in that or to what extent does someone
move somebody through that and I think
it's very important to meet people where
they're out but not keep them where
they're at but the interesting thing
with the prosperity church in general is
of course there's lots of statistics to
shoe it it doesn't work right so people
go well why do people go to your
prosperity church if it doesn't work and
the answer is you know what we think the
answer is is if I shoe you it doesn't
work you'll go oh my goodness you're
right look you know people don't get
wealthier in the church than in the
wider community it doesn't seem to have
the effect and so then once you're
presented with the information you'll go
alright I'm going to leave but that
doesn't happen right so the question of
course is why does our not happen and
from a psychoanalytic perspective it's
actually because the very fielder is
what keeps you in the church so
basically you continue to get this
fantasy that if you gots the money then
you could get rid of all of your
problems you could escape all of your
suffering so you've got this incredible
fantasy right if you got the money you
would be confronted with the reality
that it doesn't work right
the ho so the very fact that it doesn't
work keeps you going back so that you
can continue to have this fantasy that
that that continues to drive you
so if actually a prosperity Church
worked the prosperity church was shut
down because you would get the million
dollars and you'd go oh this gets me a
nicer char oh this gets me a nicer
mattress for my bed right but but it
doesn't fix the existential angst that
is amazing well I mean it just makes me
think how will a lot of churches not
every single Church I want to like just
make a broad sweeping statement but a
lot of churches it's like you they make
you feel guilty and then you you know
you go home and you try to like do the
right thing and then you come back to
church they make you feel guilty again
and you go home it's like this vicious
cycle of failures almost yeah there's
something in me that wants that so a
good example would be say you go to your
church and you're sitting there in the
pew and you're gone I don't really feel
that close to the absolute or go
whatever and and it maybe if I read the
Bible more maybe if I prayed more
whenever maybe if I became an elder
maybe if I became because all the elders
they're having cappuccinos with Jesus
and in the room at the back you know
they must have up right so you've got
this fantasy but then imagine you're the
type of person who goes right I'm gonna
burn my record collection I'm gonna do
the missionary work I'm gonna become an
elder what happens is you get to the
center and you realize that the center
is no better than the edges so now
you've been confronted with the
fragmentation of that fantasy now the
sad thing is at that point you probably
have your pension and you okay so you
have to stay with or not but but if
you're in the pew you you keep the
fantasy alive that if I was if I was the
pastor everything we create but once she
gets the center you realize the center
doesn't hold and I so this is what Oscar
Wilde meant when he said there's only
one thing worse than not getting what
you want and it's getting what you want
and of course because when you get what
you want you realize it's not what you
want no I I when I came to America
because I a family a credibly generous
family here deep friends of mine they
had a private foundation and they
offered me fiercely a patronage for
three years so I came to America and not
Foundation supported my work for three
years I went from a piss their squat in
Belfast to this to America and I was
lent a house in one of the wealthiest
places in America and I lived there for
three years so I was a I was around the
people who in a sense had one had got
the American Dream and these are people
he had not not millions not tens of
millions hundreds of millions on
sometimes billions and it was
devastating for me I for me personally
but I also saw in that community some
people who were very healthy and very
happy and some people who were very
depressed and and in very difficult
situations and so that's what I mean by
even the winners lose the losers lose
doubly because you can't eat so you
can't put food on your table you have to
work too hard but if you ever got the
the lottery ticket win you might realize
that while it can help in some material
ways as I say I slept I had up char that
had two heads two
I was lovely so you had a char it's like
oh wow money can get you a two-headed
shark that's brilliance you know and and
the house was at a really good
temperature all the time and I'd love
that
but you know it doesn't take away from
the trauma that is that is humanity it's
because there are two types of trauma
the traumas that happen to us and the
trauma that is us there is a true there
are traumas that happen in our lives and
there is the trauma that is life itself
and we need to find another way to Terry
with that trauma can you expand on the
distinction between the two traumas
there because that's fascinating to me
and I've been doing some some deep dives
and into recent history and trying to
I've had some really significant health
traumas in my life a few years ago I
thought I was dying I had just a bunch
of really bad issues health issues going
on that I've subsequently fixed but I
there is the sort of psychological
residue of a lot of that and some of its
associated with with geography some of
its associated with certain people or
whatever and in trying to untether the
that residue from the people or places
is more difficult than just cutting a
tether you know it's like it's trying to
get the onion flavor out of the soup
it's pretty difficult yeah well that's a
great example by the way I'm sorry to
hear you have to go through that but
that's a great example of the difference
one more thing is so you had health
problems and you were confronting the
post real possibility that you might die
that is a trauma that happens to you
that that hasn't happened to me in the
same way but then your doctor maybe says
to you it's all right you're fine and
then you're like okay so I'm gonna live
now if your doctor was a philosopher
your doctor would say well no no you're
still gonna die no life is a terminal
illness right um you're just not gonna
die of this that's the what's called the
ontological dimension so the draw the
the kind of traumas that happen to us is
oh my I nearly died I had cancer I
nearly got hit by a car and then the
deeper trauma of life is oh no matter
what I do I am facing death and again
somebody might have trauma of like drug
abuse or poverty and
pass that's a trauma that's contingent
to your life but then there is the
trauma of just being human and having to
work with a type of sense of existential
lack that no matter what you try no
matter what car you buy no matter what
house you get you can't get away from
this sense of meaninglessness how much
you achieve and especially in our
culture that's that's the word this
whole minimalism thing resonates with
people you know Ryan and I minimalism
was basically the Trojan horse for us to
talk about whatever we want to talk
about because there's there's this this
in our culture it's the trinkets of
success that often come to the forefront
it's the the selfie of the expensive car
and and you know you talked about the
prosperity church it really it's the
aspirational side of things that that
draw people into it but then also once
you figure out like once you get there
get halfway there for me it was working
in the corporate world right and I grew
up really poor but but we we and we had
phenomenal success in our 20s climbing
the corporate ladder it worked our way
up to really high middle management and
I oversaw an entire cubicle of my
fiefdom and you know all these people in
these cubicles and and I managed all
these retail stores and but the closer I
got to the people I aspired to be like
yeah I realized that like wow that as I
got closer you know the the the image of
them I had a boss at one point who was
on his second heart attack and third
marriage and he just turned 50 yeah and
it's like well wait a minute if I work
my butt off for the next 20 years I
could be just like can I follow the same
recipe I'm gonna bake the same cake
that's the example of even the winners
lose you guys were winning sure and even
you and you saw through it you saw oh my
goodness this system is the losers lose
ee but oh my good even if I succeed
within this freedom I'm losing and then
you me at a minimal ISM begin
philosophers called the master signifier
what he meant is but it became the way
to react that free and that's exciting
you know the biggest thing we're getting
from this this conversation is a how
important
is to live in the moment like no matter
where you're at in life to to find some
way to appreciate what you have and then
the other thing is Josh and I talked a
lot about lowering expectations but
raising our standards and when it comes
to love when you know that quote that
Josh brought up about you know giving
something that you don't have to someone
that doesn't want it it's like you well
the best way that I can explain it is
like living in Los Angeles my experience
with it it was really rough at first
yeah and I was telling Josh about this
I'm like dude I love LA but LA doesn't
really love me and he was like well
what's wrong I'm like dude I go to like
coffee shop hey how's it going and
they're just like yeah can I take your
order dude like what drugs are you on
why are you so happy what do you want
out of me who do you think you I mean
there's like all these prejudgments so
Josh he's like do you have to you have
to turn it down or you need to turn it
up yeah so I said all right I'll turn it
up so now when I have those moments
where I walk in somewhere and now like I
haven't regular spots really people you
know they pretty much know me by now but
you know I'll go somewhere hey hey I'm
Ryan nice to meet you how's your day
going and they kind of give me that what
do you want to do what drugs you're on
I'll be like can I take your order you
can't take my order but first I want you
to tell me how your day is going like
I'll just you know just be kind of silly
and goofy and I I will express that that
you know the kindness or the love that I
feel yeah without any expectation of
getting it back yeah and sometimes I
don't get to back and that's okay but I
will say that when I a like I'm in the
moment with that love and I push through
that barrier I will have much better
results and results that I didn't expect
so you know when Josh and I were having
a conversation and he was like yeah I
would recommend turning it down or
turning it up you know when I first
started turning it up I just thought I'm
just gonna make an ass of myself now
like when I go to different places but
are you're very good yeah I really I'm
very very good at that but it's but it
turns out I'm about 20% good at that
because the majority that nerd 10% I
mean the majority of the time the vast
majority of the time when I push through
that barrier without so I'm living in
the moment I am giving without any with
any expectation of giving back that is
that's raising my standard that's what I
mean that's what we mean by raising our
standard my standard is be myself be
genuine push through be honest
and be consistent those are my standards
I don't expect Josh to treat me anyway
if I act that way I don't expect you to
treat me a certain way if I act that way
but what happens is by by forcing I'm
not forcing that but I guess pushing
through that that the trepidation of
being ourselves that truly to me is what
is what is freeing I guess is when you
can you can again love without expecting
to get loved back um and and you can
just yeah raise those standards and keep
the low expectations because you know
when you get when your expectations are
so low it's it's you're really surprised
with the results you get a lot of times
I think it's as long as those standards
are high too I of course you know so we
have Pete's book here which you can't
get unless you're a patreon supporter of
his it's called enduring love because I
think there's only 500 copies of the
thing but but like it would be great
because love is so difficult to endure
and that's the thing we haven't gotten
to is that love is lovers are very
difficult this brings us to the heights
but also the depths anyway key what was
the thing that I think about with with a
book like this it with respect to
expectations versus standards like it'd
be really great if all of a sudden this
was so what a million copies in New York
Times bestseller like that but if that's
your expectation going into it even if
you get that like that's gonna feel
fulfilling in for a moment but it's
gonna be fleeting the standard is like
hmm but can I write a book by the way
this has a bunch of you know it's a I
guess you would call it like comics or
illustrations but with like all of these
little pithy aphorisms parables etc
about enduring love and the the standard
is like I'm gonna put my best foot
forward knowing that it's not going to
be perfect it's never going to be
perfect it's not going to be the
superhero version but I'm going when you
talk about living in the moment I'm
going to enjoy doing the actual work of
creating this thing yeah there's an
interesting distinction in philosophy
and psychoanalysis between pleasure and
enjoyment and so of course we use these
words interchangeably in everyday life
but you can distinguish them by saying
pleasure is the good feeling you get
from say you know
finishing the book an enjoyment is the
pleasure you get the the warm feelings
you get from the work itself so for a
Christmas time you see a kid waiting for
their Christmas presents and they almost
hear that and they're jumping up a not
having a temper tantrum and all of that
but there's an enjoyment they can't wait
to get the present that's enjoyment and
then pleasure is the moment that you
open the present and we all know that
that the enjoyment is better than the
pleasure right right that's what you
when you buy a holiday you're not just
buying a holiday you're paying for the
fantasy of the holiday that's that's
kind of fooled it into the money that's
why you should never buy a holiday off
the cuff or a lottery ticket your one
dollar isn't for the wind you're paying
a dollar for the fantasy of the wind
right so and so we often think that
pleasure is the key that they end but
actually we have to find how do we get a
warmth and a depth from enjoyment which
is the struggle that's where that's
where love is because I think we those
ephemeral things we mistake for love but
really love is that deep pursuit yeah I
think about remember Ella on her my
daughter's five now but when she was
when she was three for her birthday I
got her a pineapple for her third
birthday nice and it perfectly
illustrates exactly what you're talking
about there there was pleasure in the
the opening of it but the the enjoyment
what was the anticipation she sold it
rat and you could tell was a freaking
pineapple there was a pot it was a
pineapple shaped president but like the
the the the open it there was this sort
of fleeting ephemeral thing but
everything leading up to it yeah that
that enjoyment the anticipation was was
really what the what was memorable of
the experience this can get us into
actually an interesting critique of
contemporary society and just very
quickly I think for many of us we have
an e/m oh if only I had enough money if
only I was able to buy that place you
know if I only I was able to get XYZ
then I'd be happy and we're unhappy
until we get it right and the problem is
if we get the house then we want to Isis
or for Isis or one of me what a 30-hour
exactly exactly I wonder what that would
be like now I have to try that so what
happens you have to try that later yeah
but the weird thing is then what happens
is you don't enjoy your enjoyment the
science we were to say you don't enjoy
the actual struggle of life which is
where all we Camus talks about it being
the rabble the rabble unlike the
revolutionary the revolutionary wants a
ton and Google a utopia and they're
unhappy till they get up the rabble is
the one who enjoys the work towards the
Utopia realizing that they'll never get
there and basically what I'm trying to
do with my work is that is to show that
that this is the only place in America I
think this is understood is in sports
right because in sports I noticed this
you know an American football right
nobody ever wins right you're watching
minority people win games but nobody
ever wins American football like there's
not a point when they do a super Super
Bowl
we finally figure out who wins the
Arbogast are playing for the ball or
something right so that's this team wins
the ball then we finish football and we
invent another sport right it just goes
on forever every four years is no Super
Bowl or one year whatever um so it's
like um it's unless funny because you've
got like Oh sports people understand
that actually the real enjoyment of
sports is not the wins if your team wins
every game we all know that that becomes
very unenjoyable yeah like it comes on
awful you want your team to lose - right
there has to be a particular tension
there otherwise it yeah and we talk
sometimes about friction and and I think
quite often we're looking for this
frictionless life but without friction
you have no traction to move forward you
just sort of slipping and sliding
everywhere and that's that's no good
either
there was a horror film in nineteen
seventies about this kid in this big
building and a psychopath he was
terrorizing the kid and I will II walk
in the Chocolate Factory right in this
crazy shoe and obviously Willy Wonka's
the devil right the only movie my
daughter's ever seen by the way is that
right well that's terrifying
scarier than it's really scared by
frozen for some reason - like she was
refused to watch
movies no sorry this is truly terrifying
because what you discover he's the devil
at the end when he says when they're in
the wonk of theater because he's very
very narcissistic guy so everything's
named after him you know but he's in the
wonkavator and he says to charlie he
says he he suddenly says to me skips the
cursors I don't forget what happened to
the kid who got everything he wanted and
when Charlie was what happened and then
a big evil smile and Willy Wonka says he
lived happily ever after
right now why is that a curse well
there's a beautiful you ever watch The
Twilight Zone
yeah there's no Twilight Zone of this
this bad guy this criminal gets shot he
dies he wakes up and there's this guy in
a white suit and basically says I'm here
to welcome you to your new life and the
guy pulls out a gun says give me all
your money and this guy pepper laughs he
says you can have all my money in fact
they come back to the house I'll give
you even more
anyway to go back to this mansion a big
mansion and the guy says okay I want to
see the money just open a drawer there's
millions he says I I think you like
gambling don't you so they the Brockie
valentines his name says you like you
like gambling rocky yeah let's go to the
casino and he wins every game and anyway
rocky school and like this is a bit
weird you know I I think this is the
afterlife and this is it I named a pip
goes away and two months later Rocky
Valentine calls pip up and says I'm
cracking up he says he says I go to the
casino and all ideas win so pip says
well what percentage of times would you
like to lose and said no no no I said
I'm cracked up is I shouldn't even be in
heaven this is terrible and of course
it's a Twilight Zone pip says whatever
made you think you were in heaven this
is hell and then it says you know Rocky
Valentine is condemned
so you live happily ever after so the
idea that if you wanted to climb Everest
and you could immediately do it without
the struggle and the tree and it would
be an even worse it would be hell yeah a
pleasure machine the and this is up
there's a this is one of the problems so
there's a thought experiment wait if you
could have everything you wanted would
that be better than being moral but the
point is if you could have a pleasure
machine a virtual reality machine that
gives you everything you wanted
instantly that would be horrific that
would be terrifying it's actually the
obstacle that really gives us the
enjoyment in life woods
you going back to the football reference
um I do fantasy football so Josh's sport
is basketball of mine is American
football and I won last year and I won
like with everything it was 11 1 and 1
and I was just like I won those first
like you know 10 games or something
going undefeated and it was boring oh
yeah and I'm like God like I wish that I
you know get a little more competition
but looking back in one night so when I
won didn't feel that awesome Amy knows
great because I think you know you put
in 20 bucks yeah you won 50 bucks I'm
like great I'm the best finishing player
you know out of these guys but it's
funny because winning didn't make me
feel awesome when I you know the
previous year where I finished second to
last I didn't feel awesome I was jealous
of you know the people who were ahead of
me yeah but the reason why I play
fantasy football is because I love the
research I love digging into injuries
and stats and I mean there's there's so
much that goes into it than just you
know picking people and try and try to
win games and it you know just going
back to that that pursuit so when I
think about that when I had with fantasy
football it's not the win it's not the
winning the whole the whole tournament
that makes me feel good what makes me
feel good is that man I really did the
work and I did the work I don't want to
say better than other people but and of
course you know in American football you
get lucky a lot but so I got lucky a few
times but my point is it was like when I
look back it's not the it's not having
that championship win on my belt it's
about that work that I put into it
because you're right if I could just
stand up for fitness a football league
and then I'm automatically declare the
winner it's again there's a philosopher
and literary theorist called Rennie
Gerard very good theorist and he has
this beautiful story and basically this
sums up something that sounds weird when
you first say it which is when people
win all the time you will generally find
that they will self-sabotage at some
point they'll either become a shoplifter
and you go where they show up lifting
when they've got everything they want or
they'll bring out a terrible album
whenever you know they don't have to and
so why is it that success breeds
self-sabotage and Rennie Gerard has a
beautiful example of a guy in a stony
field and he believes that there is a
treasure under one of the rocks so he
goes through the field always
overturning
rocks to find the treasure and then Reni
Gerard says eventually this man will
seek out a rock so heavy that he cannot
lift it and what when is Gerard means as
he says that when you keep you know
either
missing not getting what you want or I
mean you could almost make it a
different analogy that under every rock
there's treasure alright is that you
keep getting success you lose you lose
the struggle you lose the the fantasy so
what eventually you will do is you will
try to find an obstacle that you cannot
get beyond so making money is a good
example if you give yourself to making
money
1 million 10 million a hundred million
there's no limit to there's no way for
animating money that fixes it so
eventually what you'll do is you'll set
yourself maybe a target or an obstacle
so heavy that you'll never be able to
reach it because you're frantically
wanting to not get what you want that's
that's what we do understands we think
we frantically want what we want
no we frantically want to not get what
we want to keep the fantasy alive so we
are in this very difficult position
Schopenhauer called he says human beings
oscillate between p and suffering and
boredom this the suffering of not
getting what you want on the boredom of
getting it no I do he's most pessimistic
philosopher you'll ever read is very fun
to read him he's he's very fun
oh yeah Germans Europe has very very
good philosopher Oh dark dark dark but
there is I believe a way to get out of
this free and I think what you're doing
is a theory and a technology to do down
Piru theologies what ideas a theory and
a technology that brick this freedom but
you know we may not get too high debris
occur in this session but at least we
can isolate what the problem is and
that's the problem it reminds me of what
Ryan and I we were just playing
ping-pong for our YouTube audience right
before this right when you came in and
we we ended up tied because they they
made a stop playing because it was
midday and there's apparently ping-pong
hours downstairs and anyway like we are
about we're both aggressively mediocre
is how I describe our are playing at
ping-pong
but like we are about the same exact
skill level and that's what makes it
interesting because I know that half the
time I'm probably going to lose I'm the
the achiever of the relationships of 51%
of the time I win but I think it's
because one percent of the time Ryan
sort of lets me keep the dynamic go
honestly I think what happens when we
play ping-pong and I don't know if
there's a metaphor with with this but
usually the person who cares less about
that particular game is who's going to
lose because I know that's when I lose
is when I'm like you know what I really
don't care about this game it's like the
opposite never I care too much about is
when I lose Oh interesting I think that
actually lends itself to our
personalities you know in the with the
Enneagram I am A three and Ryan it was a
seven yeah and you know Ryan just very
carefree living the moment Oh whatever
one else wants to be happy I'm like yeah
I want people to be happy as long as I
win but but also recognizing the
downsides to both of those right and
realizing like okay I might have a
particular predisposition but I I can
climb over the prison walls that I've
built for myself as well you know it's
interesting man because talking about
these struggles that people consistently
put themselves into or like self
sabotage there is some certainty in this
right like when I think about people who
family friends who ever reach out to me
for help on a regular basis there they
have they experienced the same problems
a lot I'm trying to know like not bash
my friends and family because I'm really
not bashing them but but there is this
there's a psycho wait than before we
started but but you know the thing is
though is when I look at someone who is
constantly self sabotaging or they're
constantly making the same bad choices
well you know there is some control in
that they know the result that they're
going to get they know they're going to
fail so I think that's an aspect of just
how important certainty is in our lives
when I think about the the you know the
journey versus the end goal it's almost
like instead of instead of aiming for
sess instead of aiming for the perfect
life instead of aiming for the perfect
amount of stuff or whatever it is it's
like we have to really look at the
journey we want to choose in our lives
and there's gonna be multiple journeys I
mean it's not you just don't choose one
journey and that's you know that's the
fallacy - we feel like oh we got this
one journey and this is what we're gonna
do and be passionate about the rest of
our lives born to be an astronaut or I
was born to be whatever now do you think
that some of those people that you're
talking about friends family etc who you
didn't maybe they're addicted to the the
self-sabotage addicted is my failure I
think they're addicted to certainty hmm
I think that someone who is constantly
self sabotaging themselves especially
someone who is making the repeated bad
decisions they it's the gambling they're
addicted to the losing their term making
love is a good example of this right
because when you think about here's a
new film is it patreon supporters to get
it soon actually come wait for everybody
else you film yeah you know it's called
making love but can you talk about the
title because it's not what people would
often think about yes yeah it's also
commonly called a guide to making love
if you want to watch that yeah a guide
to making love in the show notes and you
can buy all this at his website as well
Peter Robin your tags you'll definitely
get a lot more listeners a lot of more
people will search I realize a lot of
people are searching for guides to make
in love at all what I thought it was I
know they're very disappointed so yeah
the making love used did the free is a
treat people to make love basically
right we think that two people make love
but actually you need a third person to
make love this is the mistake yes and if
you want to give me a call sometime
yeah I practice it every day yeah it's
basically like if you all school idea
was you would go on a date and you'd
have a chaperone with you right and
today we think the rule of the chaperone
is to stop people doing something on
toward but actually the original rule of
the chaperone was to get you to start
fantasizing about what you could do if
the chaperone wasn't there to stop it so
the shower you know the chaperone was
making love through this you grew up
Jehovah's Witness yeah just totally
reminded me of that we're growing up
they encourage a chaperone on dates
because you know they don't want the
kids to fornicate or whatever so they've
got they've got a chaperone there to
basically you know cuz they're not gonna
start making love in front of this this
third person but yeah yeah I totally
agree with you it's like that shap the
chaperone what it's doing is is it is
it's telling it's putting a restriction
yeah and when you put restrictions on
things it just makes you want to do them
even more yeah I mean here's a great
example in America you guys created a
technology to help young people have sex
and I'm interested in like why you did
that in the 20th century in a society is
very permissive
basically it's like it's it's a ring
that you put on your finger and it's
it's basically then stops you from
having sex so you busy put it on and
says I will not have sex until I'm
married right so what that does is it
then makes sex really exciting so and
you're more likely to have sex and I'm
like of course of course the technology
would be invented here because whenever
there's new prohibition and sex becomes
more if you do want your kids to have
sex talk about it all the time but what
did you do what where did she touch you
or did he touch you can you here's a
diagram can you show me your kids aren't
gonna that's gonna put them off for life
yeah um so there's a certain sense in
which prohibition and obstacle generates
something exciting and when people
self-sabotage it's often because they
are frantically and in an unhealthy way
trying to bring obstacle back into
existence that's why a lot of people
have affairs if you take I I knew a
couple he had an affair
called Jack and Jill thing I talked
about this in the
Robel podcast as well but busy they are
married for a lot of years the sexual
desire had diminished and they you know
there were friends with nothing else and
then he ended up having an affair with
somebody else right very brief affair it
was finite she the wife was very upset
he was kind of going like yeah well I
don't want to be in this relationship
anymore
so he got ready to move right so there
you have an example where he's having an
affair and he's saying to the woman if
only I wasn't married we could be
together right fully I didn't have this
and that no it's the opportunity if
you're an alien from outer space you'd
be like oh they're gonna break up she
doesn't like the husband the husband
doesn't really like the wife he wants to
be with Snow White Collar right um but a
week later
snow white side of the picture and the
husband and the wife are sleeping
together again still annoyed with each
other about having sex and planning at
holiday night why is that well partly
because in this example the guy is an
obsessive neurotic and the woman's
acting as hysteric neurotic so for an
obsessive the only way to keep desire
going is you desire what you don't have
so he was desiring Snow White because he
couldn't have her what's called the
object of desire is what you want on the
object cause of desires what makes you
want her right so he can't be with Snow
White the object of his desire because
of his relationship as soon as the
relationship ends and he can be with
Snow White he no longer desires her and
then for the woman she can only desire
what is under threat of being taken away
so for her the object of desire her
husband the object cause of desire is
Snow White so what happens is this
couple is unconsciously frantically
trying to find a way to get their desire
going again and this is the way that
it's and of course the truth is this has
happened about three or four times right
this is very common like consciously
it's all a mess but unconsciously
they're all trying to have to keep
desire alive because desire is what
makes us human
now of course there's healthier ways if
who do business there are healthier ways
to do this but you've got to understand
that for example some people some people
like you're very jealous you shouldn't
be jealous but some people can only love
when they're jealous they can only
desire what they're jealous of so if you
got rid of the jealousy you'd get rid of
it
all of this is just to say that if you
don't find a healthy way of enjoying
struggle if you don't find a healthy way
of having antagonism in your
relationship you will find unhealthy
ways of expressing that struggle and
that antagonism and the unhealthy ways
will destroy you I think I accidentally
stumbled into one of these healthy ways
in my own in my own relationship so
Rebecca and I spend about every other
week apart from each other and just
because of circumstances she has to go
back and forth from from Montana because
our daughter's biological father is in
Montana so I we spend a considerable
amount of time apart now we're both
introverts which makes it pretty
sustainable for us but what I've
realized in doing that like there is
this tension that builds up and that
week away where I'm lack can't believe
we have to spend this time apart but it
builds up that desire again yes yeah
yeah and so the the the other thing that
the came to mind was my mother was a nun
but well before me and my father was not
a priest but in in I talked to me like
we was in her early 20s oh it's almost
like she decided to go do that instead
of late you know how young men joined
the military for four or five years she
was like the army well sure you didn't
join the military back then as a woman
back in the 60s but she needed you in
the convent and became a nun and she's
like she's the prohibition on sex was
like driving her crazy
she used to masturbate to the the statue
of Jesus on the crucifix which was like
the strangest metaphoric seems like
something out of a David Lynch film yeah
but there's only two mothers I know that
would be comfortable enough sharing that
information his mom and my mom was
totally fine with with communicating
about her she was very open yeah she had
me late in life too but so she was very
open with those those kinds of details
but what you're talking about there is
like in a way like that restrict that
that's like the sort of the ultimate
restriction
you know putting the the veil on so to
speak quite literally in this case and
that's where the restriction but
actually becomes this actual right left
and you get this actually within and I'm
not saying this is what your mom sends
you being a nun but within the fetish
community where someone where the sex
actually isn't the issue is were the
sexes the sexuality is in the
prohibition so it so it within fetish
communities often its its Pru
prohibition that that actually it's not
that the obstacle generates the desire
to have sex the obstacle and sex are
intertwined and one is the object of
full prohibition they're like right I
mean because part of it is like well
this is naughty and that's that's what's
one of the reasons we're doing it but
then also the prohibition of of the act
itself right so it's like a double
prohibition and it's basically
prohibition on steroids when it's
actually whenever the prohibition
becomes the sexual act and that's a
whole interesting area in itself but in
religion you see it is like a lot of
mystical experiences are very sexual you
know if you look at some of the inch the
pictures of the the Mystics I'm trying
to think of is it Jillian at large
there's a various female mystics for
example he it looks like they are having
an orgasmic experience in front of the
crucifixion that's a very common kind of
fear no Barry combines the common theme
with in mysticism so yeah it's kind of
fascinating all right a first question
today is from Britt in Toronto over the
years I've tried to perfect the art of
relationships and I think it backfired
because currently I am staying out of
relationships because I can't figure out
how to break this pattern I have with my
partners where I will do what I can to
make them happy and it gets to the point
where they kind of get everything they
want and they kind of get sick of it I
think it's kind of similar to eating
your favorite dessert every day of the
week it kind of loses its value it you
kind of don't want to look at it anymore
now I've made sure that I spend time by
myself doing my own things that's very
important to be your own person but what
do you do when you get really good at
making your partner
beat and then you kind of ruined the
happiness for them so we perfect we're
always chasing perfect aren't we yeah
that word is the word that stood out to
me she says she's trying to perfect the
art of relationships and sometimes that
we have this sort of idealized version
of something and also like that I'd not
even ideal but the perfect version and
then of course ideal changes over time
to right I'm actually reminded of this
this little New Yorker cartoon that I
cut out here there is a butterfly and
and well it for those of you on YouTube
I'm sure Jordan will put this up on on
the YouTube channel but the caption at
the bottom says look I still fit into my
old caterpillar skin and like there's
this butterfly who's like like trying on
trying on the past to a certain extent
and as opposed to maybe learning from
from the past and and and so it sounds
like there are some lessons to be
learned from the past relationships here
with with Britt what do you think Pete
yeah I mean I thought was a father
brilliant question fits so neatly with
some of the things we talked about you
know if I as brittany is utter name if a
Brit Brit if I you Brits you know I
first of all I'd be interested to find
out if she felt that she needed to be
the object for their her mother's
satisfaction or her father satisfaction
because sometimes we replays called
transferrin sweetie occur earliest
relationships and we replay them in the
present so if a child feels that they
have to satisfy all the desire of their
mother or their father that can play out
and how they relate to leader
relationships so that's a question for
Brit to ask I don't know what the answer
would be that's a good question that's a
great place to sori yeah
because let's assume it's its father in
this case right and we can go through
both scenarios here what what what she
would say well yeah the my father mother
never accepted me he never really showed
me loves I felt like I always needed to
feel meiotic he always he he always told
me how I was inadequate so yeah yeah
yeah or in a very basic way cuz this is
weirdly one of the
one of the things that we have to
overcome when we're young is it's
actually quite can be quite suffocating
if if our parents actually give us the
feeling that we are their everything and
or that we come if you or if your
parents unhappy that you think if I can
fill that lock I can be the object of
their desire yeah and it may not even be
the parents that have you know created
it because it's a very natural thing for
us to desire but if we get into that
freedom of mind then we think of
ourselves as the object of the other's
desire and we're always trying to find a
way to fulfill up and you never come ya
know the reason why you never come is
because people's desires oscillate and
Chi engine a parents who basically makes
you think that you are their everything
it just as I said causes certain
problems in the future but also then in
terms of the reason why this doesn't
work in relationships is because as
we've just talked about is we don't want
everything here we do want the other
persons who try to be everything for us
it's a fantasy but actually in reality
that extinguishes desire we want yes
that's always key is like and that's why
I find it funny when people ask me even
like what do you believe as if we knew
what we believe my goodness we have no
idea who we believe like do you believe
saying God or do you believe like nobody
nobody believes that a duvet cover
protects you from a knife attack or
makes you invincible to an enemy but if
you hear a creak downstairs you get all
Harry Potter and put it over your head
right do you believe it you just do know
what right very few people believe in
goose until they hear a topping outside
the window and then they're terrified so
we actually have all sorts of beliefs
were not aware of and we have all sorts
of desires that we're not aware of so
the big thing for Brit is for me just I
would if I knew her and we're talking
therapy to try to work out whether she
has this sense in which she needs to be
the object of the other's desire and
that can actually be suffocating for
both parties
so it sounds to me like when she says
that she's constantly trying to make
them happy it's this is calls her to
start staying out of relationships now
and that that the the men that she's
with are getting everything they want
what you're saying is maybe that is
selfic aiding them or or uh if you pan
out it's suffocating the relationship in
a way it's in it's it's self-destructive
it's not intentionally self-destructive
or but maybe it's subconsciously
self-destruct Linda I know in past
relationships where I've had the you
know my partner go out of their way to
just give me every single thing that I
wanted I can remember one with you in
particular yeah but it was a great
relationship but until it wasn't right
it was like what if I just kept took
this water I kept pouring it into your
glass like you need more water it's it's
overflowing yeah but it's actually
creating a mess the other piece of it
too is I want to be in a partnership I
want to be a team I want to live life
together I don't want to have an
extension of myself I don't want to have
a third arm or you know a second brain
that I can attack I mean I really want
someone who is confident someone who is
willing to stand up for themselves and
to a large extent that's great that they
know what I want but I want them to know
what they want also so I think the other
thing too is with I don't think it's a
relationship you're thinking of there's
another relationship this um I
definitely wants it the name her I was
dating this girl for like three weeks
Jessica yeah and her mom called me three
weeks into it it was like you know so I
was really upset right now and I'm
first off I'm like what your mom's
calling me you're like sure her mom's
calling me telling me she's upset like I
have no idea where this is going and she
was like she's really scared that you're
gonna break up with her and it's funny
because that phone call is what made me
break up with her mmm there's this keep
going I mean I don't think I really much
more than either but just there's a
level of immaturity that happens when
when someone it's a feeling of
immaturity I'm not saying is immature
but like that that example where her mom
called me likes which is perfectly fine
she's sticking up for her daughter she's
worried about her daughter but like that
that phone call that she that her mom
calling me and saying well you know
she's worried gonna break up with her
like that to me is a feeling of
immaturity it's the same thing with the
girl that I think you're thinking about
there is a level of just this feeling of
immaturity when someone is constantly
giving giving giving giving giving
giving giving giving they don't know
what they want themselves they just know
that they want to give to you as much as
they can
it's or maybe it maybe it's not
immaturity its underdeveloped
or not fully developed maybe you know
way looking at it I think there's a
great book called on being normal and
other disorders and I love the title
because yeah it's a great title because
I think that like if you're normal for
example you do everything right that's
weird I mean if you if you have the job
9 to 5 and you were the suit and you do
everything in a very regimented way
that's a really weird for a mental
illness right so so in one sense we're
all we're all messed up in different
ways so yeah this is just a this is just
what this person is having to deal with
and because here's the thing the most
precious thing in the world right the
most what is it what is the most
precious material in the universe well
it's desire what do we desire we desire
the desire of the ones we desire so what
what is most impressive is the desire of
the ones we desire that's so important
to us even when we're fantasizing about
being wealthy or being famous you got to
understand that we're fantasizing for
somebody else who is it our mother or
father our siblings our enemies at
school who is that he we would either
want them to see us famous or you know
because they wouldn't do it or because
they'd hear us right
we found that we are fantasies are never
private they're always for someone else
it's always good to ask hear you
fantasizing for so so so once we once we
because it makes me think about my own
self where I'm so like I've never been
happier I've never felt more purposeful
I just I I'm gonna really love
I am today um someone hosting yeah but
but you know I've got I've got mom and
dad issues where like they I could walk
on water and they would you know they
would have something to say about it
right exactly water isn't a deep enough
multi Python sketch on that yeah but but
you know I guess um because it's it's
making me do some self-reflection here
because I know that there's got to be a
piece of that where I'm constantly
trying to live up to someone's standards
now I I have been able to work through
and kind of you know let go of those
expectations let go of the relationship
that I really really want to have with
my mom or the relationship but I really
really want to have with my dad it's
it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen in my lifetime and that and I
have totally got past that but I guess
um I don't know how I got there so I
guess what I'm asking you is like so
once someone finds that person that
they're really trying to please yeah how
did they how can they move past that I
guess that's the case for maybe for
someone like Brit I don't know that
because which you desire the desire of
the one you desire desire is different
from satisfaction in fact satisfaction
destroys desire whenever you give
someone everything they want you get rid
of their desire then they become off got
everything I want right so what happens
unconsciously is maybe you know Brit is
trying to evoke the desire of the other
by thinking up by giving them everything
that will satisfy him that is then
destroying the relationship yeah so so
what you kind of almost have to do is
going like well Brit doesn't have to
change anything she can still want to
give the other person exactly what they
wants what do they want they won't
desire so in other words you have to
build in some sort of struggle and
impossibility and antagonize the
relationship but it can't be too much
struggle either yeah because that's
crazy like going back to the you know
parents who raised someone with
everything that they want it's like
that's going to create probably not the
most developed or I don't know what word
I'm trying to use a mature person but
the same thing holds true on the other
end of the spectrum if a parent doesn't
give a child anything then that's also
going to cause some kind of
development immaturity so there is
finding this balance of of the healthy
the healthy desire yeah healthy
attention is really where I was going
with that
there's the healthy tension builds the
the desire right yeah yeah I think the
two best relationships I've ever had in
my life the two times where I felt like
I've been in love and one was with
Colleen who I wrote about and everything
that remains and lay that's exactly what
happened I reached this level of sort of
peak satisfaction and it was this
amazing relationship and if you put the
pros and cons on on a sheet of paper you
intellectualized that the thing it would
have been like well of course this is
amazing and this is gonna last forever
and and of course the the what left well
and I didn't know this and at the time
but what left was the desire and I got
to this place where I'm lay and almost I
felt this this well The Melancholy you
that you described before where it was
like I got what I want
and this isn't saddest this is
satisfying but that's it right and I've
lost the desire in fact there's this
this this other New Yorker cartoon the
second one I found today and that was
sort of the problem like with doing the
if I were to put all the data on the
spreadsheet and intellectualize that
relationship like well what's wrong with
you hmm and and this was perfect there's
a lifeguard who's yelling at a person
who's drowning in the ocean right so
we'll show that on on YouTube here but
the lifeguard instead of going to save
the person who's drowning uses a
bullhorn and the caption here is just
says remain calm and list your goals in
order of priority like like that's you
your intellectualizing like a process
that requires the actual the something
that goes deeper than that there's this
this emotion that you're missing from if
you just look at the the sort of data
it's like looking at a a rainbow and
grayscale its inner that so for me what
that cartoon represents is sometimes you
know like you can read any you know
every single Tony Robbins book that you
want you could read every you know self
motivating book that's out there but
sometimes people are legitimately
drowning and and they just need to put
aside the self-help for a second
and just focus on getting above water
and and you know metaphorically like you
know that's it's easy but first for you
know in practice it's gonna be a little
different for everyone who kind of feels
like they're drowning so so maybe what
maybe what do we do to sum up birth
question here what do we do to to inject
that healthy tension into a relationship
yeah okay that's difficult by the way
just one thing on the self-help stuff
which other is it Greece I think is in a
sense that great opposite of self-help
because how do you define grace
Greece use a Paul Tillich I think said
it very well which is to accept that
you're accepted so it's not a religious
term or anything like that as such it is
merely a sense in which you're able to
experience an acceptance of yourself
another self-help is going like you know
T X step two step three step four Step
five Greece is this weird moment that we
get very occasionally where you go I
don't have to judge myself condemn
myself I can face myself and the weird
thing is when you are able to make space
for yourself that real change can happen
like an a a before you do the 12 steps
there step zero and step zero is Greece
it's where you sit in the room where
people accept you and don't ask you to
change and you can be honest with
yourself and weirdly only when you can
do that can you make progress so for
Brit or me or you guys anybody the first
experience is to go
I've got ghosts as in I've got things
that I've repressed that goosed is the
presence of an absence so we're all
haunted houses we've got ghosts of those
we've loved and lost those we've heard
those who have hurt us and the first
thing is to go I I need to I need to
look at those ghosts because there are
there's like obsessors they're condemned
to as soon as they get to know somebody
they stop desiring them so a typical
obsessive they can only desire what they
don't have but a typical hysteric can
only desire when they give themselves up
completely when they disappear so you
know someone who always brings gifts all
the time give themselves completely to
their kids to the point that they
disappear entirely and those are two
very damaging forms of relating to the
world and I think the first step for
anybody is to stop and to go why is it
that I am afraid of myself or I'm afraid
of encountering the other and that's
Greece is very hard to find it's very
hard to experience that build in some
some tension here healthy tension I mean
I think it's first recognizing the need
for it because quite often we want to
eliminate it like anytime there's any
friction at all it's like get this out
of here I want this to be ideal and to
be perfect I want it to be Stepford yeah
but that's when the satisfaction
overwhelms you until you're no longer
satisfied here's the thing I would love
to see a marriage right where because
here how do you make an engagement
romantic right because everybody's
trying to do it like fireworks and get a
you know a ring in a pie Deadeye his
wedding yeah but I understand that we're
frantically trying to make engagements
romantic because we've taken the one
thing away from engagements that makes
it romantic the most romantic thing
about an engagement is that to be
engaged is utterly ridiculous terrifying
and horrifying right the idea that that
you would impose yourself for life on
somebody you like is horrible I mean
that's disgusting to think that you
would impose you're not even Anatomy but
someone you actually care about and
secondly most marriages don't work right
even with the ones where people don't
separate are usually a disaster no I
think this is what makes marriage
wonderful because imagine you're about
to get married
and I say to you I am from the future
and in the future you guys Bria couple
it's a disaster in fact I've even got a
DVD or whatever memory stick with it
with the moment of you guys break up so
it's not even you know statistically
probable I'm sad it's going to be a
disaster and you're gonna use your kids
to fight among each other
if you then turn Ryan and say yeah but I
want to do it anyway that's love right
so it's so in one sense I want a
marriage which kind of where the pastor
says you're doing something utterly
ridiculous this is insane
the probability is within five or ten
years you won't just dislike each other
you'll hear each other more than you
hear anybody else in the world and
that's what makes it beautiful because
you're willing to take that risk you're
willing to jump into it a hundred
percent but that kind of Marge rarely
happens in our society because the
marriage is seen as
the ghoul and and this not the struggle
but kind of the the achievement of the
end so for all of us Prince Heidi how do
we ritualize the reason why I'm using a
merit is because a marriage is a ritual
that is designed to embody a mood of
existence so how do we find rituals that
that actually help us understand that
relationships are a struggle or a
nightmare are probably well worth
avoiding and that's why you should jump
into them you know Britt said she's
taking some time right that's fine we
all need to do that but you know what
she's she's already had the insight
she's had the insight that relationships
are a nightmare no she just needs to
take the second step and go and that's
why they're worth jumping into the love
yeah Indu because I'm this is the comic
with the graphic novel you know is that
it's all about because this is it's a
set in the lonely forest I play is
called the lonely farce it's very close
to the Hundred Acre Wood but lesser new
one and it's all of these little animals
who are trying to injure love they are
trying to enjoy the sufferings and the
joys of love it's very dark and
depressing but it is it is just it's to
show that love is so difficult to do and
yet love is what brings a depth on a
density and a complexity to our
existence the relationship I'm in right
now with with Rebecca is the most
difficult relationship I've ever been in
and it's also the best relationship I've
ever been a part of has to do with just
pre-existing circumstances we both bring
baggage to the table obviously because
you know we're we're in our mid to late
30s and and so like you you you come to
the table with your own past right and
instead of trying to ignore that you you
recognize it and you can even celebrate
it in a way that says okay I am
perfectly imperfect
I am yeah I'm all of these pieces you
know I'm I'm giving what I don't have to
someone who doesn't want it but you're
willing to take it anyway yeah and
you're willing to endure this
relationship otherwise like it's it's
just perfect and so gonna hate it so we
have given Britt the most perfect answer
right now she's gonna dive back into
these relationships what happens when
the next one fails how do we how do we
encourage her to embrace the failure
yeah I mean it's it's really tough I
mean yeah the Heidi and you're the
horror of love how do you cope how do
you find life after death yeah the only
the only thing I can say and no one I
don't believe this I don't believe this
but it is that when here I don't know
what to be true yeah yeah that's
probably a nice way to put it is that
thankfully we can all change the past
this is a wonderful thing is that it's
also terrifying but we are weak it's not
just that we care about deleting old
tweets yeah yeah Deloria we have but we
have we can do it not only can we
influence the future we can change the
past and what I mean by that is if
someone is in the dark darkest despair
and for 20 years they have been in the
darkest despair and they haven't met
anybody and they're like I just wasted
20 years of my life if you meet somebody
for example it can rewrite the past
suddenly the past is this weirding
period for this movement it becomes the
old testament prophecies of this event
in your life and it really proves and
riku defies the past and so what I
always want to say to people is in the
pits of despair I know it's hard to
believe but when you find something that
you love in the present
it can also Riku defy and transform the
past so your past is never unredeemable
in fact your path so you know your past
is always redeemable you have not lost
anything but so that event that event
will not just change your future it will
change your past so keep going keep open
yeah and it's tough you know um I mean
I'm a TD I got two thoughts going on
well just to bounce off of what you were
saying I know the interview did with Rob
I think it was in the part 1 episode
where you talked about how that past
sometimes it creates this barrier it
prevents us from like loving fully and
like just letting go of that past is
it's the scariest thing but it's
something that is so necessary for us to
move forward the other thought I had to
is you know this conversation actually
is really helping me feel good about
failure not just with love but with
anything and as we're sitting here
talking I was kind of thinking to myself
is there anything in life that we get
and we are just a static that we got it
and we're so happy
but we didn't lift a finger for it yeah
is there anything that we get in life
that comes without the friction that's
worth having I mean maybe there is that
means it's probably someone watching
this or listening to it and they're
gonna say oh yeah I won the lottery and
I'm really happy which which is funny
because most lottery winners aren't
happy but anyway I guess I'm pausing in
that question is there anything you can
think of Josh that we get without any
friction and we're so happy we got it
I think the lottery would just destroy
most people and and because it's it's
the opposite of what you're talking
about yes but there my interview is yes
but they're there they're all things
that still come with tension and turmoil
like yeah I mean there aren't things at
all right it's not and it's not the sort
of it's not objective reality it's
subjective reality we we get life and
that makes me really happy that I'm
alive but life is a lot of work and it's
a lot of struggle a lot of pain I was
thinking the closest thing I could think
of is when I was a kid I just remember
you have these moments when you know as
you're growing up like oh I can't wait
until I can you know throw a football
like so and so I can't wait until I can
ride a bike like so until and you have
these these these little moments that
that you you do get growing up I mean
that is you know for all intents and
purposes even then right I was gonna say
riding a bike even then I can't tell you
the amount of pain I'd put through
myself I put on myself turtle under how
to ride a bike but even growing let's
just say the act of growing up as a
child you still have growing pains even
even if you get something like a glance
of a stranger you're walking down the
street and there's a glance of history
and you're not glanced for some reason
lightens your day so you can say though
a lot Kym without friction that was a
gift from the other without friction but
even then there's a whole pile of
reasons why you needed that glance oh
yeah it's a it's hard to imagine
something that that comes to us without
a history of prehistory yeah my friend
Phil Harrison wrote his debut novel
recently called I think it's called the
first day he has a great line and I
think he might have taken annoyed at the
book but he said the line is one of the
characters
none of us gets what we want but you
cannot get what you want in different
ways
and and it's a beautiful line because it
was like yeah there's better and worse
ways of get of not getting what you want
right
there's failures that are terrible and
there's failures that are good and
actually and back it says this but
there's a certain way in which what we
want is the better ways of not getting
what we want we find the ways of
enjoying our failures and and you know
in a positive kind of way now I think
the biggest piece of advice for Brett
here is embrace the healthy friction or
embrace the healthy tension yeah you
could tweet either those Sean those are
good too
all right well Brett I'm gonna send you
a copy of our book everything that
remains since I since I talked about it
and there's a whole chapter in there
about the second best relationship of my
life at the time it was the best
relationship of my life and how I how I
ruined it she's still in your top five
on myspace everything that remains will
send you an audio book version of that
or a copy yeah well said you copy
I'll give you a copy I'm gonna send it
to you right here oh yeah I'm right here
I'll take it with me I'm no I don't
believe here that you'll stand it says
you know dues a society that doesn't
know us history is condemned to repeat
it but that's true for us as individuals
as well we will continue to make the
same mistakes that we made in our
childhood and actually to know your
history is to maybe break out of it and
not repeat it so if someone like that or
anybody else we repeat the past and our
present relationships when we don't knew
it but if you can begin to get to knew
your past it actually helps you free you
for a lot anyway that's all I wanted to
say we put this sort of veil over the
past and said I don't want I don't want
to dive into that I was actually talking
to my therapist about this yesterday
about how so how because he was asking
me about like what are the things you
don't confront in your past and and
thankfully over that there was many
things for the first 30 years of my life
but then I started writing about the
things and and it's cathartic but not in
a way that's pleasurable yeah you you
have to like dig up some some demons
from the past in order to to slay them
anyway so that is a way of changing the
past
by confronting it so Brett will send you
a copy of everything that remains if you
like the podcast you like the audiobook
version or if you want the book book or
the eBook version podcast shun if you
could reach out to her and send that to
her I would be grateful our next
question is from Justin in Cleveland
there was a woman that I was an in
relationship with I brought me immense
value and I loved her very dearly but
she broke up with me so I wanted to know
when is it time to move on and say the
relationship is over and when is it
still a time to continue to pursue that
relationship so it's interesting the
again the language that he's using it to
posit this question so this woman broke
up with him and of course I just want to
I want to put this caveat out there I
mean obviously know as know and if
someone breaks up with you and they and
that you they don't owe you anything
they don't owe you an explanation they
don't owe you an hour of their time too
so let's try to work this out they don't
know you totally together when someone
tells you no you should respect it yeah
absolutely now that said also Justin
sorry for your loss like this is
obviously huge loss for him so I want to
empathize a little bit with him yeah and
I think that the other language he used
here is when is the time to move on and
he's give up and and I would just say
that now is the time to move forward now
that does that mean moving on or giving
up I don't know Peter I heard you talk
about this once like sometimes when when
you get into an argument with your
significant other and someone says get
out of here they don't actually mean get
out of here sometimes - there's that
there is the literal meaning but then
there is this sort of the there is a
figurative meaning behind get out of
here it also means stay and let's work
this out no way yeah no yeah and
language is a complicated thing in
Justin I you know I've been in a similar
place and you know so many of us hopping
and it is deeply devastating one of the
things I would say is what did he injure
that happens when you break up with
someone is that they're very breaking up
changes the dynamic to such an extent
that you start to fantasize that the
other person
could fix everything so what happens is
often when a breakup happens the person
isn't just somebody really nice that you
could have had a good life with the
person starts to become in your
unconscious fantasies the one that would
fix you entirely the one yeah that's the
key to our friend Cullen Wright has a
great book called some thoughts about
relationships and he has these different
like chapters in there and one of them
is about not looking for the one like
the the whole Jerry Maguire thing you
complete me is like yeah in fact I think
in the book he's he's you want to look
for the person that in completes you yes
that you in complete me is is the more
realistic yeah because really when you
say you complete me it's you complete me
for right now what but also it
presupposes that you are not a whole
person by yourself and that you need
someone else in order to fill in this
sort of this inadequacy that you
currently contain very existential so I
avoid even the wholeness words but we
already have to get an exact but here's
the problem I would say that
psychoanalytically we are all very
susceptible to the notion of the one you
see in philosophy the one is the
absolute or God in LA there's a tyranny
of happiness the the one is fear more
money or looks so we are very prone to
and the reasons are because it's what's
called the drive we have this dry for
something that will complete us we all
have that temptation and so in in this
environment for Justin this woman come
tick top spot and it's there's no easy
way out except sometimes it'll be a bit
of a bit of psychotherapy or whatever
but eventually you get to the point of
going maybe it would have been a good
relationship maybe it would have been a
great relationship maybe we would have
had a wonderful life together but that
but it wouldn't have completed you the
what's happened that she's become an
idol she's become a figure that is so
absolute that you will not be able to
enjoy your life
alternative to an idol then yeah yeah
kind of in one sense to break the idol
very gradually you kind of need to brick
this fantasy of the one and it's very
hard to do to brick but to brick this
fantasy and it does mean for Justin he
may as as I say go she's a mirror and
that would have been fantastic but it's
also going but you know what
I have other possibilities other life
opportunities other things will open up
but it can take years to to get to that
point you know it's really it's really
really tough and because you're not
consciously making the person the one
you're unconsciously doing it so no
matter how much you consciously try it
and not do it you're fighting you're
unconscious and your unconscious is much
stronger than your conscience of giving
up I mean the the thing I remember a
particular relationship I was in it was
with the woman who threw scissors at me
and we won't go into details but there
was a time where we got into a I'm not
prone to fight and I'm also I take
things very literally when you know
she's like you get the F out of here and
I'm like okay I'm walking I say where
are you going and I'm like you just told
me to leave like I was having yeah I'm
leaving is before the the scissors
incident ended everything but but yeah
it's like get out of here and I'm like
okay like I respect what you're saying
goodbye and and then it's like well
where the hell are you going well it's
funny cuz like what she and I I I know
who you're talking about in their
personality and you know she might have
thrown that out there get out of here
but really she wanted you to fight for
her right which I don't know if that's
healthy or not but there are some women
who like to be chased there yeah and I
don't really I think men especially yeah
because we can often be you know
achiever and for me like significance is
a big drive for doing what I do right
like and so I have to I have to keep
that in mind like the question you asked
earlier like Who am I doing this for
right and and like Who am I trying I
were to
and then why and so so maybe we could
talk a little bit about that maybe we
could talk about these sort of the
language behind the language yeah I mean
and this this is the core of language
itself whenever in America there's a
philosopher she's act about this and
I've experienced it myself in America
you guys say how are you doing
I think it's whenever you go into a shop
people say are you having a good day or
whatever and at first it's very weird
because you're like oh well thanks very
much for asking well I just had an
argument with my mom and I was out my
sister's being like yeah you was in
hospital and you know and then you
realize no they're not out they're not
asking you that right I'm being an idiot
they're not asking you how is your day
going they are showing that they're
there they're making a connection so you
guys from American knew that but I don't
back in Ireland
we always refuse food twice before the
third time so if I come right to your
house and you say would you like some
food I'll always go no and then first
time in America I did this I said no no
I couldn't eat a thing and the person
said okay and I'm like hi rude so you
could like you know you could like if
you also fear to go no no I really
couldn't
oh no seriously have a sandwich no no I
could like I honestly couldn't eat a
thing no no please have a so much he
hasn't far much right that's the thing
so again you there's an interesting that
in every society there are the rules and
the matter rules and when you go into a
new society you just knew the rules you
don't know the matter rules this is one
way of always knowing if someone doesn't
fit so if you go to a high-class dinner
and the person does everything right
well you knew that they don't fit
because to be in a high-class dinner is
to know when to obey the rules and when
to disobey the rules if someone Abbes
all the rules it's obvious that they're
trying too hard
so you know I actually I've got lots of
examples of that but so even whenever I
say to you I want you to leave I'm RIA I
might be saying I want you to fight to
stay if you're in a relationship and and
it's very difficult to write the meta
rules the matter rules or the shared set
of rules that a culture or a community
kind of knew
and this someone outside the community
is completely oblivious to this could be
just the two people could be just that
relation you might have your own metal
rules you have your own materials and
very you know people who are very kind
of psychotic or have psychosis of sorts
they're very literal so whenever they go
to a party they find the party
completely bizarre because everybody is
lying you know saying it saying how are
you doing but they're not asking how
you're doing they're you know they're
all of these they knew the rules but
they don't know the materials and so
parties are this weird space where
everybody's lying but of course
everybody's not lying and if people are
just knew that matter rules yeah so that
it's an interesting thing about language
oh by the way also indirect
communication the most direct way to
speak is indirectly ie you know if I say
to you I want you to leave well I want
you to stay but how do I find out I only
find out if I say I want you to stay
then you can stay even if you do want to
right but if I say I want you to leave
and you go no I really want to stay and
work this side then I get to the truth
that's the difference being a parable
and a command right if I'm in the army
and I say it's cold in here close the
door right close the door you have to
obey me I'm giving you a command you
have to do it but if I go horse chilly
and here if you're a nice person you'll
close the door if you're not you won't
right and so a parable speaks to the
heart a command speaks to the you know
the mind and a lot of language has to be
parable I can house in order to find out
something you you can't speak directly
yeah yeah I think that that in in
Justin's case here I mean you have to
take literally if she's like hey we're
done but then also they're not knowing
how long you've been in this
relationship there probably is some meta
language here that you have to know
whether or not you are moving on is this
worth one more one more shot is it worth
one more discussion and you have to
respect if she says well no I don't want
to have any more discussions I'm going
to block your phone number or whatever
or we just need some time apart you can
you can still approach that literally in
a way say hey look I realize what you're
saying to me would it be possible to sit
down would you be willing to
five words that change everything for me
would you be willing to sit down with me
for half an hour so we can talk about
this rationally and afterward if you
want to walk away totally understand
that there is a mess I mean it's
difficult because we all know there's a
messiness to relationships and so
there's a way if someone says for
example no we've broken up there's a
messiness there but there's a way to
respectfully deer for example you don't
stalk up stalking is where you basically
then don't take no for an answer right
but there's another thing which is where
you send a letter and in the letter you
say listen this is how I feel this is
where we're at and that's a bit messy
because the person said like maybe I
don't want to ever talk to you again and
you've disobeyed it because you've sent
them a letter that's not stalking
stalking is where you are refusing the
new writing a letter isn't isn't a bad
thing no writing a hundred letters under
text month you know the person's
expectation and they have really poor
expectations where where for me like
there's a relationship I'm talking about
where she was like get the hell out of
here I'm like okay like that was
honestly the best thing to do in
retrospect as well because like she
literally wanted to stay and fight and
like it was an unproductive it wasn't
like stay and fight for me it was stay
and fight with me there is a structure
that's very painful for people you have
up where they can only minty in their
desire through conflict through jealousy
through fighting and that can be very
taxing on a relationship unless the two
people like it and then it kind of can
work okay but sometimes somebody they
have to eat ya know yet conflict not
because they like the conflict but
because the conflict is what allies than
too minty in their desire but if you're
not that type of person I'm not that
person
yeah and that type of relationship is
just gonna add really worse words if
actually two people I knew I know a
couple and they're very fiery and
they're always argue you know but it's
like a they both love us and I look out
and go hard my goodness that would be
exhausting to me I couldn't do it but
they um they're in it for the fight
they're in it for the fight and they
love us and they're like and I honestly
first time I met them I was like oh this
is a bit this is a bit happy they're
having this conflict energy
and then as I hung out with them as I
owner they loved each other so much and
they get so much out of this tension
that's how they define passion in a way
for them whereas for someone else for me
that would wreck a relationship and so
you have to figure out those own the the
rules and the meta rules of a
relationship in order for it to work I
was going to send Justin a copy of
essential RS a collection there's a
chapter of relationship about
relationships in there but actually
since we talked about Collins book Shaun
if you could reach out to Justin and see
if he would like a copy of both of those
are our book essential which is an essay
collection 150 different essays about
intentional living one chapter about
relationships in there but then some
thoughts about relationships by Colin
Wright is a great book he has these
different policies about not just the
intimate relationships in our lives but
how to better navigate our everyday
relationship so their business
relationships friendships acquaintances
etc so if you could reach out to him and
give him the book or the audiobook
version of those I would appreciate it
so with Justin if he has already put in
this this healthy pursuit you know and
she's not giving you anything back you
got to let it go but the other thing too
I want to tell Justin is you know really
look at because she may or may not have
done this for him I mean he didn't say
but I'm gonna assume she gave him a
little bit of feedback like no I don't
want to be with you because of X Y & Z
either directly or indirectly right and
and Justin can look in the mirror and
this is what I think he should do he
should look in the mirror and say you
know what she's right you know X Y & Z I
really do need to do need to focus on
and that's an area that I've always had
a you know problem with and then you
know start start having those you know
short term actions aligned with those
long term values and beliefs that's the
things like it like you know generally
one person's problem is another person's
desire so for example you if for
argument's sake somebody might say you
know you're too you you're too
passionate or whatever you just fly off
the handle too quickly but then there's
some people right there go no I want
that so you know the the bit and the big
thing for me for Justin is is I guess he
has let it go us and physically as an
who you know but I'm
he's more talking emotionally Heidi I
let go in my mind and I think what
you're saying is very important which is
I think to let yourself feel everything
to let yourself feel like don't don't
run away into other pursuits into work
or any things there's a the beautiful
freezin in creative yards which says
gone but not forgotten
which means someone's died that you who
remember them but in in psychoanalysis
there's a notion of the forgotten but
not gone which is where you try to
forget something but it remains within
you that tears you apart where where you
pretend it's not there yeah you keep
eating you know the soup even though
there's a turd in it you're like this
kind of tastes like [ __ ] but you just
keep eating it over and over and over
and you try to like pretend it's not
there but it's it's going to be there
until you deal with it so going with
this you know the shit's do example um
what I was getting at is that with
Justin he can maybe look in his stew and
be like you know where she's right
there's a piece of [ __ ] in this stew or
maybe he looks at it looks in the sunís
like no this is actually really good
stew and I really really love this stew
and even though she feels that way like
don't I guess what I'm really trying to
give advice adjust in here is like maybe
there is something you have to change
maybe but but ultimately if he can look
in the mirror and be like no I really
love Who I am and you know I don't know
why she broke up with me and whatever
reasons it was and I really don't agree
with her but I really do love Who I am
well then Justin you've got to find
someone who loves you for who you are
and she don't love you for who you were
that's okay if you can't do that that's
the last of trickiness sometimes we
can't do what can't move on like and
that's very important for all this is
like it's not because there's
consciously you know what you cut
conscious advice and then there's the
what the unconscious wants and that's
why I'm always actually very skeptical
of advice because advice always talks at
consciousness when we have to shift the
unconscious and so hiders if if Justin
for example is you know he wants to move
on he wants to forget but he can't what
does he do and that's where that's where
I think this trying to just feel
everything honey baby get a therapy
where you're you talk through everything
and you bring it all to the surface and
that just that process can be enough to
Bria
that psychic link it might help you it
might be the thing that helps you move
on by bringing to the surface and and
yes you're you're letting it go in in
one sense but it will follow you for a
while and even as you move forward
killer cut and burn all our stuff make
it burn all the photograph so the other
option is to try to feel your thoughts
and mourn and move on or to project your
thoughts all right sure we'd love to
hear what you have to say so you have a
comment or tip about love including
advice for any of our callers today
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
will air our favorite comments and tips
on a future episode and stay tuned to
the end of this week's episode for this
week's listener comments and tips Ryan
what time is it it is time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media IP this is
what we do here we were on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists and and and Pete is at Peter
Rollins on Twitter he has my favorite
Twitter bio of all time I think I wrote
it down says will give nihilistic
despair for cash and then it says tweets
do not reflect opinion of my employer
self-employed that's great so yeah you
can follow at Peter Rollins on Twitter
but during the lightning round this is
where Ryan and I and now Pete we do our
best to answer each question with just a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text of these 180
characters that's its to 80 to 80 but
we're you know we're we're
fundamentalists alright you're still
you're speaking of so so Pete has a
great podcast with his roommate called
the fundamentalists he's reclaimed the
word fun to fundamentalist so your
roommate is is a comic yeah and I think
it's weekly you you put out a podcast up
in those most weeks mostly yeah the most
organized guys like I'm looking at your
setup and I'm like sooo and all but we
Center pajamas drinking whiskey if you
ever to come by and you talk the set
here I think it would take away some of
the beauty of it you talked about this
on a recent episode where you were
talking about the sort of issues that
you had
with Malcolm Gladwell talking about
stand-up comedy and I really love the
episode because you your bushy roommates
Elliott Elliott yes yeah you and Elliot
we're talking about how Malcolm Gladwell
made this very declarative statement
like how stand-up comedy is one of the
easiest jobs in the world because I'm
being a bit hyperbolic but basically he
was saying that hey it's so easy because
you're showing up and telling jokes in
front of junk drunk people who expect to
hear jokes and and I think the beautiful
day taunt that you sort of formed with
this conversation is like Malcolm
Gladwell was both right and wrong like
like the part of it is like stand-up
comedy is really difficult and because
it's difficult you have to put yourself
in this situation where people are
coming in to say and expecting to laugh
in a way it's only as difficult as
telling the truth so which is incredibly
different yes I I know there's one thing
like it's I virtually knew no one who
can tell the truth except your truth
always speaks your truth will speak in
the top end of your finger so Freud said
or the twitch in your eye so everyone is
always telling the truth but also we are
avoiding confronting the truth and so
the the comedian often is trying to
articulate a truth that isn't that's
very difficult anyway in that episode
you were talking about also how why when
YouTube stars start to become famous
they actually lose the the thing that
made them so fascinating because they
were just like everyone else and then
all of a sudden they're no longer in
their bedroom singing the cover song
they're there Shawn Mendes performing in
front of 50,000 people at a stadium and
in Dublin or something and all of a
sudden they're not that same person that
you fell in love it's like when when
Radiohead became famous and everyone's
like yeah but everything went downhill
after Ok Computer because all of a
sudden that they're this they were they
were cool for not being cool but now
they're cool which makes them uncool
yeah with that wait a minute this is
this like you're my pleasure my
enjoyment is not having it because I'm
looking at your setup and I'm like
you're my ideal you're like that
you've got like you got a room you've
got a really good but if you guys really
want to be so unhappy
yeah but in my head I would be happy so
I'm gonna go back to Elliot and go
Elliot we need you know that up to your
point Lake so we just had the Today Show
we did a Today Show interview on the
megan kelly show and we were gonna film
at Josh's place but there's some kind of
issue of filming his place but his place
is so much like he actually looks like a
minimalist when he walked where we're
like where me and my partner you're
walking you're like oh these guys are
like really tidy i mean josh is really
tiny - but specifically with design as
what i is what i mean but you would walk
in to be like oh maybe this guy's
minimalist because of the specific
design like and I think OCD and I look
and and I go to Josh's place oh my god
this place is like so nice but if I had
this I'd be miserable because I would
have to take care of it I would have to
make sure everything was always in its
place and I and it would drive me
because I am NOT OCD I am a DD but to
your point it's like I would love for my
place that look like Josh's I just don't
want to make my place look actually can
you just come over and like decorate and
that's given to you make you happy
that's absolutely true
alright so for the lightning round we
actually just monitor on a bit so don't
feel like you have to create something
hundred forty characters eventually we
come up with something that's tweetable
or Anya we get to our first question
here all right our first lightning round
question is from mystery girl does ever
learn a mystery girl was her twitter
name yeah nice it is a cool superhero I
thought maybe like someone like
anonymously asked a question or
something on all right mystery girls
question is what do you recommend to
someone who doesn't really know how to
love herself
well my pithy answer to this and maybe
we could talk about it is internal
clutter gets in the way of love thus to
love ourselves we must let go of that
which is in the way emotional clutter
psychological clutter is spiritual
clutter mental clutter existential
clutter Pete we often talk about the the
material possessions in our life like in
American life and particular Western
society in general but we didn't have
people from Afghanistan and Kenya email
us natives of those countries who are
like dealing with this straw
with external clutter and so what I've
learned is part of the human condition
is like there is this this material the
material possessions are a physical
manifestation quite often of what's
going on inside us yeah right and so so
it's quite often it starts with dealing
with that stuff but once you deal with
that
then all of a sudden you have to start
looking inward in a way yeah so mystery
girls question is about like what do you
recommend to someone who doesn't know
how to love herself first so so the
short answer I got here is the more your
shirt good grief
I promise the shirt does what I promise
I can talk the more your short term
actions align with your long term values
the more love and respect you'll have
for yourself and isn't that quite the
problem sometimes it's like we get down
on ourselves but then we realize and
then it becomes this like perpetual
cycle to like like I'm not doing what my
future self would want me to do right
now I mean the the obvious example is
like someone who's a smoker like you
know your future self probably doesn't
want your current self to smoke you're
gonna wake up the next morning and be
like why did I go back to the cigarettes
yeah yeah yeah we beat ourselves up I
mean that is to me like that is well
that's kind of the human existence it's
like like you talked about there's where
we're at where we want to be and it's
funny though if I ever got to where I
wanted to be if I ever got to that
perfect state I feel like I'd be really
bored yeah like I feel like if there's
not any more challenges then then life
would be really really boring so I mean
in another way I guess I'm recommending
to mr. Eagle is embrace the challenge of
loving yourself and embrace the the
journey of finding different ways to do
that but I know for me when I hate hated
myself the most or when I looked in the
mirror and I felt like I was letting
myself down the most it's when my my
short-term actions were not aligning
with those values so for example it's
like I really wanted that you know
mid-level corporate job I wanted to
manage you know hundreds of people and I
just I really wanted that well to get
there there was a lot of values I had to
compromise I mean selling self teaching
my guys how to teach
to sell cellphones to five-year-olds and
and you know trying to play the
corporate politics and I mean there's
just so many things where I look back I
just forsook a lot of value so I could
finally get this thing that I wanted and
then when I got it yeah it was a
completely different feeling than what I
thought I was gonna get yeah
so give anything pithy for mystery girl
she doesn't love herself yeah and I
first of all these guys had practice
they even wrote down their answers this
is I am hearing it off the cuff so
that's I'm gonna make my way to pick the
answer buddy quick a little pretty quick
so to two problems people have often
when we're growing up is we either we
create what's called an ego ideal which
is like our even ever your parents say
you're strong you're beautiful whatever
which is very important but you know you
you start to create this ideal of
yourself that you love what's called
narcissism you start to fall in love
with this ideal there's another issue
you sometimes when you don't really it
to that ideal you put it on to other
people so you start the idolized stars
writers musicians which is a weird thing
of like putting your ideal leguan to
other people so there are two issues is
you you love the ideal of yourself or
you love the ideal of yourself in
another person you see it all the time
the difficulty is is how do you confront
all of your shadow your darkness your
all of those things and how do you find
a space for them and it sounds like
mystery girls you know that's a question
she's asking she's she's saying like I
don't have that ideal ego that I'm
loving which is a very good thing so
you're already halfway there mystery
girl yeah you don't have to overcome yes
you I don't know if he idealized other
people but it sounds like maybe not but
you know so the question is then how do
you come to accept your your whole self
in its darkness and light and the pithy
answer this is my Twitter answer it got
there and that's very twee but it's it's
fine in a collective of grease which is
to try to there's a long answer but the
short answer is where is it that you
feel that people can accept you for who
at the coffee shop it could be the
confessional the poker room the pub
wherever it is where is that liturgical
space were you're able to allow yourself
to feel the full range of human emotions
from happiness to sadness to self-hatred
the self of all of the human emotions
that are there and just make space for
them in your life if you don't have that
space try to find it and it's hard to
find I love it finally find the space
where you can be yourself as opposed to
having to always try to be that
idealized self that you're projecting
onto the world disagrees because Greece
isn't being accepted because I can
accept you but you don't accept the year
that you're accepted so the first step
is goodie a place where you're accepted
and then very gradually very gradually
you will accept that you're accepted so
it doesn't happen straight away you
enter a collective where you're accepted
and then over months or years you will
accept that you're accepted and then you
will be able to love yourself in a
healthy way
absolutely it's why I got a have an
aside written down here and it says
don't let other others opinions make you
think less of yourself get those people
out of your life I mean you could tweet
that to Sean but the point is is like
right now does she not love herself
because there are things she has to
change because there are other people
who aren't accepting her for for yes
yeah yeah or oh yeah or are there yeah
or are other people on her life who were
making her feel like she's not enough
and and going back to what I was telling
Justin sometimes you think you know we
project so much of our inner fantasies
on others that you know you know there's
a it's very difficult to know whether
someone's not accepting you or you're
not accepting yourself
and you're projecting onto other people
yeah that's it that's something to be
taught you cannot quite often be a
combination of both yeah yeah like when
you always knew what someone's thinking
when they say I knew what you're
thinking so if someone says I know what
you're thinking you're thinking I'm an
[ __ ]
I would like no you're thinking you're
an [ __ ] but you can't accept that
you're thinking you're an [ __ ] so
you're putting it in somebody so yeah so
and it's it's a little trick our next
question is from Jess I was gonna say
Jess
all right jazz writes in how do I know
whether it's bad love or if it's good
love
well my pithy answer was better on this
one I the thing I wrote down is hate
often masquerades as love so tread
lightly and with intention yeah I think
you have to define what what what love
is here and what is what do you mean by
bad love and what do you mean by by good
love if you mean frictionless love then
that's probably not love right it's when
I think of the people who I've loved
most people who I do love the most in my
life right now
there's certainly friction there there's
there some sort of tension but it's
necessary in order for that relationship
to grow I wrote it down
if you really want to test you love ask
yourself whether you'd start the
relationship over again and what I mean
by that is is not start with a with a
fresh start
but would you you know go back to day
one when you meet that person would you
foster that relationship still and if
the answer is no you know I don't think
that that necessarily means right away
that someone's gotta like abandon that
that love that they think they have I
mean I think the first step is well how
do you fix the relationship to where you
truly can't express love and have some
good love in your life but you know
sometimes we get to a point where you
know we hold on to things I mean when I
think of literal things I mean dude how
many of our things that we let go of
that a claw marks on it man and even
though and even though those things in
our lives
they weren't something that truly
bettered our lives but it's like we held
on to them because there was this
fantasy of those specific things making
us more of a whole person or maybe it
was the letting go of the failure of
like [ __ ] man I bought this like brand
new car and I really liked it and if I
let it go and downgrade him another car
then like I've lost that way and and you
know I made the bad decision getting
this I mean we could just beat ourselves
up but but you know ultimately I've
totally lost my train of thought
the claw mark thing the the David Foster
Wallace called everything I've ever let
go of has claw marks on it that's not
letting go at all right that's just
hanging on until you can't hang on
anymore
and well I guess what I was trying to
say is like ultimately we need to we
need to recognize when we're clawing
onto something out of pride or out of a
fantasy like we have to be very clear on
why we're holding onto something that
we're holding on what cuz eventually
you're gonna be forced to let go and and
and why not let go now anyway yeah -
Boyle died in a psychoanalytic insight
is Jo's your love seek to fill the lock
and get rid of the struggle in your life
or does your love a limit and help you
enjoy the lock and the struggle in your
life I'm not better than what we got to
do this for ourselves
we always bring on a guest who makes us
some like idiots ya know you'd better
you do a good enough job without on your
own unless laughs I just I just
automated what's already there unless he
knows you know one of you while sleeping
could beat me outside like yeah I have
to admit some the judge I only look like
I can fight like an Irish guy like an
Irish guy coming out of a pub that's
good well let's move on - oh there's PS
Ryan we have one more question all right
and so this question is from just
reading mostly and this question is is
it true that quote all you need is so
play us out with the Beatles no we're
not gonna do that
alright we're not gonna do that but but
so it's fascinating there's something I
want to talk about here this is backs
and I got into an argument last week
about this thought experiment and I'm
know you you're familiar with plenty of
thought experiments but this one was
particularly painful and it had to do
with with commitment and so I do want to
talk about that if you want to hear our
conversation about that and hear our
answers of that question then you can
listen to this week's PostScript episode
over at the minimal
private podcast so Pete each week we do
a little short
private podcast just for our patreon
subscribers it's like a bonus little
episode and I want to talk to you about
this this well this argument this is
this discussion this heated discussion
that Becks and I got into and we'll do
that this week on this week's PostScript
episode of the minimalist private
podcast if you want to listen to that
you head on over to the minimalists comm
a slash support you can find all the
details and good stuff over there and
also we put out ask the minim ask the
minimal as anything episodes a bunch of
other stuff for our patreon supporters
and so here is a snippet from this
week's PostScript episode
[Music]
human beings are creatures of meaning
and we can't get into the reasons why
but but what that means is we offer
value so other creatures doing over
value beyond utilitarian means the human
beings have not even just a capacity it
might be a actually central to
subjectivity that we're able to value
beyond utilitarian use right so that's
to overvalue something and love is an
iam for overvaluing so you over value
one person other people look at the
person whether they're really dead on
they're nice and but you II think
they're the only person in the world who
matters right so love is a modality of
overvalue
[Music]
okay now it's time for our added-value
portion of the show this is where we
talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently now Ryan
we're gonna talk about screen --less
Saturdays in a second and you'll see why
I have a physical copy of a CD well josh
josh is just really passionate about CDs
compact discs this is Matt Nathanson's
new album it is called sings his sad
heart and man it is like in fact I think
at the end of this episode we will play
out the episode with with one of the
songs from here let me look at the back
of the because I have the disc here in
my hand used to be actually this whole
album is sort of about like our
unhealthy attachment to the past so you
talked about how how we can change the
past by reframing the past in a way but
he has these sort of these moments where
he you know he sings his sad heart
that's the sort of the the the the title
of the album here but that's the theme
of the album as well as looking back at
this sort of sad past and to me it
perfect the album itself perfectly
demonstrates and you don't have to get
the CD as I should surprised the CD
store that I went to had the CD because
it was the day it came out but right
there CD stores well we'll talk about
that promise but um the thing that this
album really illuminates for me is like
how we unhealthily cling to the past as
opposed to reflecting on it and learning
from it and you can't learn from it and
it's literally some of the most
beautiful writing that I've experienced
and in any format not just like in text
but he has a way with words where one of
the lines on there what does I wrote it
down here he he in the song used to be
he says I've got a king size bed and a
PhD in the way it used to be a PhD in
the way it used to like I have studied
my past over and over and over it is
it's a gorgeous album but it's there's
this weird dichotomy too because it's
strangely upbeat it's sad upbeat songs
so like you're hearing and you're like I
feel like I should dance right now but
wait
I shouldn't be dancing to what he's
talking about this is this is sad the
music shouldn't make me feel this way
there's this beautiful dichotomy there
Ryan what's been adding value to your
life recently oh man
Mariah and I we were flying I don't know
a week ago or so and you know you got
the movies that you watched on the plane
and we watched won't you be my neighbor
Oh with uh with mr. Rogers I've been
wanting to see that you know I am NOT
like the typical man's man again I may
look like a minute but I'm not like
really we were just like uncontrollably
sobbing during this whole movie you know
who recommended that to me originally
his unbelievable did whoohoo now Kevin
Rose he held of screening in Portland
for oh that's right he recommended it to
us when we were there yeah and and it
was incredible man I mean it helped me
feel so good about what we do because
like mr. Rogers he dedicated his life to
helping kids and like that was his
purpose yeah and that's what he went way
out of his way to do and and you know we
have it's it's like when I was watching
that movie I was like you know what like
I'm so passionate about what we do you
know if the rug ever got swept out from
underneath of us and it just you know we
just whatever like Josh cheated on me
and you know I left I mean [ __ ] hit the
fan yeah and like I you know I had to
like really reconsider what I was doing
and I was homeless like I would be on
the I'd be the crazy guy on the street
corner with a big sign that said have
less stuff like I would still propagate
the hell out of this even if I was
homeless right in it did you believe
yeah it just really really helped me but
it's it's a UH it's just an awesome it's
a very inspiring story here's the other
thing too with this movie I don't know
how many kids mr. Rogers helped out I
mean thousands tens of thousands
millions l was a fan and it's funny dude
it's funny because watching this
documentary I real there's this voice
that we all have you know the voice of
talks to us in her head and I realize
like that voice is very much influenced
by mr. Rogers because I was watching you
know this documentary it's showing these
old clips and Mike all might like the
cadance the soft tone I'm like holy [ __ ]
like I had no I thought it was like God
or like you know my dad something like
that but it turns out like the when I
really look at that internal voice that
talks to me especially when I'm like
trying to calm myself down
it is totally mr. Rogers huge huge
impact on all these kids but here's the
thing he had his two children in this
documentary they were talking about
their dad and there's nothing negative
so is my own perception this is not
anything that's in the documentary but
there were very little interviews like
there were only a couple lines by their
kids and one of the lines that that
their kids said was like the only the
only person the only person worse to be
raised by than Jesus Christ is his mr.
Rogers and because you because he felt
like you know he felt like he was with
this you know this christ-like person
growing up and you can and I could tell
that you know he reached all these kids
but like his kids were not a product of
of his teachings or of his pursuit you
know I don't know what to make of that
but you know there are the it's I mean
going back to where I really wish my mom
and dad accepted me the way that I
wanted them to but they don't
out of all the people in the world I'm
sure mr. Rogers wanted to like really
touch his kids the most and it's like
you can tell that he he missed was it
his fault was his kids fault was his
wife's fault who knows but it's just
interesting how you've got someone who
you know so very much wanted to help
kids and like and he did but the the
kids that he probably wanted to help the
most you could tell he didn't completely
get through - yeah that's a very common
thing that that the more we have an
external persona and we're projecting
something right in the heart that the
more perfect that is often the more
imperfect our private lives are so
there's this thing I've been in America
called PK's past your pastors kids I
think it means preachers kids forever
and you know it's a very common
experience of people who you know
someone's full time job is to be caring
and doing missionary work and often what
you find is that there's a poverty
within the private life so anyway I
I'm fascinated by by that world the not
not just that I mean it sounds me like
you're fascinated by the sort of the the
prosperity church and and all that it
for a certain reason I think probably
same reasons it fascinates me because
you learn from what you can learn from
the good and the bad from from those
places and I mean you're a you're much
more well-versed with that but there are
people like like I'm not particularly
religious but I found Rob's work years
ago and I found it really useful even
notwithstanding the the sort of
religious tax or subtext of it even when
he was at Mars Hill and I was in Dayton
Ohio
like like found his first book on to be
very useful and it's especially books
like like how to be here like like found
I found the stories in there and I know
some people even just just cringe at the
the idea of what religion because they
had a bad experience with it at some
point but for me it was like well this
was just a different lens through which
to see the world and and why not be open
to that perspective but there are other
you know the there are other places that
we were speaking in Australia earlier
this year in the same place that I was
in Sydney where Hillsong does their does
their like Sunday service or whatever
and and I'm fascinated by by that move
in fact I read Karl Lance's book and I I
want asked him once he used to drink
coffee in the same coffee shop was me in
Brooklyn okay that's quite funny he
walked into this job before I knew he
was like there's a guy must be a rock
star he looks like a rock definitely
looks like a rock star
and then someone was there not scar lens
and we had a wee chat yeah yeah yeah I
mean so like there's to me things that
like I can I can be exposed these
different perspectives not have to agree
with them but still get something out of
it what's been adding value to your life
recently I think you want to recommend
yes beautiful question very quickly I'm
gonna like very unprofessional and I
feel that this is the most valuable bit
of this whole interview because I am
turning a lot of people onto Peep Show
I'm sure it's British it's a British
sitcom that it's very good because you
hear the inner thoughts of the people
and so it's very good at exploring
repression comedy or is it like a no
it's a series of it
that charts the relationship between two
friends
so I'm doing peepshow and then I'm
listening to actually a band that I
really like called ballet school here at
Belfast Berlin band sadly I don't think
they're doing music at the moment but I
check them I them and daughter are the
two kind of love ya daughter but if you
like daughter check out ballet school
okay ghost is a really beautiful song
you know you know you know what I think
it's an Irish Oh
father Ted oh yeah yeah I love that show
so good and there's more like three
seasons of it yeah you know what if only
I was gonna mention this because the
people who wrote that or produced it
created a new sitcom called dairy girls
set in Northern Ireland during the
Troubles okay and it's actually very
good and it's um it's very hard to get
in America but dairy girls is very very
common to see him people eat it father
to put a link in that in the show notes
Shawn so I could go back and reference
it oh yeah first 30 episodes it's very
funny that is awesome
all right real quick let's move on the
right here right now this is where we
talk about what's going on in the lives
of the minimalist Ryan and Pete let's
talk about something called screen 'less
Saturday's we started doing this
recently and actually just this month I
in fact I want to say this to Ryan the
day this episode comes out is Ryan's
birthday so how is man you finally
caught up to me we have like a meeting
scheduled that day we do have a very we
have in a pod thankfully he Grove
Jehovah's Witness so he's never
celebrated birthdays and it sort of
stuck but um we we've we've been doing
this thing called screen 'less Saturdays
we started it October 1st and because
social media and just the the the well
the unbound 'less glow of our our
screens they're they're very intrusive
that glow is a callin all the time yeah
whenever I go to like just a restaurant
that has a TV on the wall I find that I
have to position myself away from it
otherwise like I just ignore the person
I'm with and I can't help but like even
it's something I don't want to watch at
all like it's a soap operas on I'm like
wow and and so on Saturdays
basically we have a essay on our website
about this and it's called screen love
Saturdays I'll put a link to that in the
show notes there are three ways that our
audience is participating with this so
number one if you just want to take it
easy it's just get off social media on
sad
that's one way to do it number two is
well you can get off also the sort of
entertaining screen so your computer and
and this is sort of what this part was
inspired by rob belly this sort of takes
a digital Sabbath on one day a week so
taking that digital Sabbath on a
Saturday the the the most extreme
version which I've been doing and did
last week was no screens whatsoever and
less it's something I can't avoid but
like even my phone like I left at home
all day and backs left hers at home I
know she actually left it in her purse
so we had like an emergency phone but we
didn't use it and and it was beautiful I
we literally got lost together and like
but the first problem I encountered was
like oh we want to listen to some music
together we're driving in my car let's
go down downtown LA and then we went to
Boyle Heights and light but we didn't
really know where we're going because I
didn't have the I didn't have my phone
to tell me where to go
I remembered that's actually I used to
learn a city you stop and ask someone
yeah and you figure it out but we didn't
have any music and so I'm like I don't
see the weirdest thing for someone in
this Danny is if you'd pull over and say
hearty I get to some where's like who is
this crazy crazy they tell you of a spot
and then they try to tell you how to get
there and I have to listen to him for
five minutes when I know I'm not gonna
remember any of this anyway which roadie
take me there like I don't know
whichever Road waves tells me so we
drove over to amoeba music which is like
the only CD store I know of this still
exists I'm sure there are plenty out
there but it's in Hollywood not too far
from our studio here and we went there
they actually have free parking and we
went upstairs and I bought the this Matt
Nathanson seat of the CD was it was the
day after it came out was already in the
store and I'm like perfect and then of
course my fav one of my favorite albums
if not my favorite of all time is David
Gray of all time
the best-selling CD of all time in
Ireland that's right yeah I'd like to
grab listen to it for years and so white
ladder to mainstream look at look at the
prices go kitty look at the price on
that oh my god you would have been dumb
not to get well here's the thing about
this I and I had this sort of
existential mini crisis as we were in
there because Beck's is like this goes
against everything who we reevaluate
possibly buying this dollar CD yeah and
but like we actually what there wasn't
issue I said well no I'm actually not
buying the city I'm renting it for a
dollar
because next screen the Saturday which
is two days from now I'm just gonna go
return this CD and they'll probably give
me a quarter for it or something and
I'll then use that corner and put it
toward another dollar CD and then on
screen with Saturday I'm just renting
this CD for a week and then I get to
return it to them I don't have to hold
on to this thing and then you know same
with this but here's the weird thing
this Matt Nathanson CD was eleven
dollars I remember like 15 years ago CDs
were way more than eleven dollars like
the digital version of that album would
be more did you have you looked it up
you know I have it but here's the other
thing I discovered strangely four albums
anymore either
yeah we streamed them right yeah the the
strange thing about is I put this on
because I'd been listening to this album
the day before on my Apple music and I
put this on in the car and people are
right the CDs do sound better oh yeah
not $12 better I'm not going to start I
was like I always called BS on it like
yeah come on how much better no it
sounds so good on CD but guess what the
convenience is still worth it to me the
rest time but I learned so much from the
screen 'less Saturday experiment I
realized how long I've been tethered
because I've done a bunch of experiments
in the past where I went without home
internet no TV and I got rid of my cell
phone you learn a special kind of
loneliness when you remove these sort of
pacifiers from your life and we're given
all of these sort of pacifiers that
they're injecting dopamine into our
daily existence and and we get addicted
to it but man it was so freeing in a way
because we just explored and we got lost
together and
it was one of the best days I've had in
a long time also men know if you had how
much lessons I went to gold-bug so it
was really easy for me
what's gold-bug it's where you get no
sets of hot springs you get no cell
phone service like we stayed the night
there like it was freakin awesome so
maybe I cheated a little bit this
Saturday I'm looking forward to it
though cuz I'll be in LA and Mariah we
were just talking this morning I'm like
what are we gonna do this Saturday if we
like literally try to go art my TV broke
so I don't have that option I mean I
guess we got our computers I could pull
stuff up on if we wanted to but yeah I
did no computer no TV no and all that
celebrate back sign that we read to each
other for like three or four hours
that's awesome and like I was pulling
out all the books I love this one you're
gonna love this story and for like three
or four hours we rediscovered books I
just read before my own books one
Rebecca I whatever she's into man I know
you've read this but it's really good no
I read some nonfiction sufficiently I
just really enjoyed spending the day
with no screen the nice thing about the
no screens is when I do do because I
have no screen Saturday's no screen
Mondays I mean I especially when I'm in
Montana
visiting family and stuff but having a
specific day set aside and giving
yourself permission you know because
you've set everyone with the expectation
like Jordan knows Sean knows Josh knows
like don't try to contact me on Saturday
because you're not gonna get a hold of
me so you have this permission to like
let it all go and do not worry about it
and I will say like when I go do the Hot
Springs or whatever we do go on the snow
hill and I don't have cell phone
coverage there is that that flinch we're
like oh man like what if what if Josh
really really needs me and like I know
I'm like I'm not near coverage and it's
like I can let all of that go it's like
you have permission to just to just be
free I guess we are the target creatures
human beings we do rituals whether it'll
be every Tuesday you see your friends at
the coffee shop every Friday at the bar
but we're liturgical beings and the idea
of creating liturgies of life
that help us embody our desires and help
us actually even shift our desires is
deeply important a lot of
work is about how do we create these
liturgical structures in our existence
that reform our mood of being in the
world and that's just a great example of
one of those types of liturgical
technologies perfect segue let's talk
about your work before we wrap up here
Pete I just want to thank you for
spending this time with us I'm really
really really grateful you want to talk
about me I have your copy a copy of a
book that you wrote here will show the
folks on YouTube it is called the
Orthodox heretic which in and of itself
is a bit of a paradox and all your CDs
are coaster for the book it actually
does make a great coaster look at that
can you talk about what you're working
on right now I wouldn't the minimalists
our patreon supporters of Peter Rollins
so much and so we'll put a link to your
patreon in in there in a neutral topic
going he walked in this morning we were
filming the what is it b-roll pre-roll
it's called live we were doing we were
film behind-the-scenes and Peter was
like I don't put me on camera the
government will find out that I'm
working I can't that's an Irish joke
especially in Belfast at one point it
was about 25-30 percent unemployment
unemployed like before I came here I
thought the joke was as you can move to
America and not have a job and the
government will take care of you much
easier back home to not have a job so we
won't tell anyone you're working on
anything what are you working on these
days and where should we point people
obviously Peter Rollins calm at Peter
Rollins on Twitter but what work what
what if someone were introduced you for
the first time what would you want them
to check out right now yeah well so the
actually dot book as well you can
actually get it free at the moment
because while I'm on tour with friend
Rob anyone who goes on in my web site
can sign up and get a free copy of the
Orthodox heretic I read it it's a thirty
three parables that I read with some
music and oh great with parables thank
you oh my
and so yes check out the Orthodox
heretic so they get the audio version
you get three for free if you sign up
and I'm not being generous I just want
to have your email address so I can sell
you goods and services I don't know what
to do with them to be honest so Josh and
I typically don't send you spam but
Peter will I want I want your heart and
soul no I promise I won't
I'm also I've just finished producing a
film called making love I've just
brought out the graphic novel injury in
love and a commentary called a guide to
making love so I've been working on that
the next big project I've got a cup I do
a festival and a retreat in Ireland so
I'll be doing those I'm even looking
into a documentary kind of thing so I've
got you know bits and pieces mostly I do
online talks that's what I'm mostly and
see but I have a book that's percolating
on the absurd Christianity and the
absurd so I'm excited about that as well
so yeah lots of bits and bobs well any
time you want to come back and just chat
with us we can we can chat about
whatever or if we can help on any of
your projects man let us know listen I'm
already coming back tomorrow to record
cool I'm only here one day a week and
that's on Tuesdays so that's perfect yes
have you ever check out Peters podcast
as well it's called the fundamentalist
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes but you can just search for the
fundamentalists wherever you I hope your
podcast it's not a podcast it's just an
archive of talks I've given oh great so
you know but your people find it and
mania of sticking you the interweb is an
incredible thing it's gonna be big
honestly because you can just literally
type in my name and you will get so much
stuff that you will hear the day that
you typed in drew all right you got
anything else for us yeah man I got some
voicemail comments and sips from our
listeners check them out hi this is
crystal from Seattle and I had a comment
regarding in Angela's question about her
father's items after he's recent passing
from the episode 136
what I have done with my grandmother's
belongings once she passed is I found a
few items that I actually could use in
my home and that way I wasn't adding to
the
but rather replacing an item that I
didn't didn't really have value with or
didn't have a story with something that
did so for my grandmother's I kept one
mirror and two lamps that I used
frequently in our home also when our
father of my father-in-law passed away
my husband took a few items that he
could wear that were his father's even
though they weren't quite the same size
there were a few items that did work out
that way you're getting the use out of
an item and you don't really have to
determine whether or not you should hang
on to it if it doesn't serve a purpose
because it is serving a purpose while
also bringing a smile to your face as a
memory for the people that have left hi
Josh and Ryan mrs. Emily from Oklahoma
City
I had a tip for the callers and
questions in the spouses podcast I
recently read a book called Crucial
Conversations that provides a really
clear step-by-step framework on how to
have difficult conversations whether
that be personally or professionally it
talks a lot about things like stating
your intention and creating a pool of
shared meaning and kind of shared input
um it's a great resource and I highly
suggest it hi this is Ryan from Dallas
Texas I just listened to these spouses
podcast I just want to add a comment as
of recently I mean my wife decided to
become minimalist and we had a week of
getting rid donating trashing or selling
a bunch of things and I heard a lot of
people you know that were their spouses
or significant others we're not on board
but I just want put something out there
first be ones where their spouses are on
board the best thing to do from what I
learned was you take care of your things
you know like we were going through
stuff and you know my wife is like check
it I don't know if I should get rid of
this or my you know that's up to you
this is this is your journey figuring
out what you're going to keep and what
not what brings the most joy to you and
what doesn't and I think this answering
that instead of just saying well you
have lots of things don't you still if
it means the same if that's what brings
you joy if that that adds something to
your life if you love wearing a little
shirt then keep it you know just just
give that advice don't tell them what to
do
alright Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for 0 6 2 1 9
7 8 3 9 you can also email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm and
if you leave here with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus